it's the holiest jolliest time of the
year
i think we should
based on you telling me this change the
musical open
yeah we definitely should to i mean love
you
remix yeah it should be a remix we can
do it here in the studio meghan trainor
can
put a beat on it kesha can sing over it
can you do that for me
all those things i don't trust is not
where i shine
antibiotics and music and apparently
wheat edibles are not where i shine
well luckily i'm a musician
hi hello we haven't done an open in
ashes ashes but it's courses now
christmas season christmas season
or whatever you celebrate or it's yeah
whatever you celebrate season
i don't even like celebrate christmas
but i celebrate whatever pagan ritual
you're into
sparkly is my shit
you love a limited too eclairs
you love all that i love a pure one
here's the problem me
in the holidays uh first tangent of the
day
i'm such a perfectionist and the
holidays trigger me so intensely
that if i see a price tag
on a driftwood elk
antler a driftwood elk and like a drone
a driftwood elk that state that goes by
the fireplace yeah it's a christmas elk
and there's three different sizes and
it's the little family of elks
yes that costs six that only come out
during christmas
yeah and there's a price tag on the hoof
like i'll get up from the table and
everyone it's
a price tag on an ornament why do they
put price tags
on the string of the fucking ornament i
don't know nothing is worth when they
stick a
sticker price tag on something and then
you peel it off and it leaves that
residue
and yours ruins the candle holder
when they put on books when you buy a
book and there's a sticker on it that
says like thirty percent officer
just put a sign up hate you surprise me
at the register no
they're not brewing less sane today
because of you
yeah i don't even buy books 30 offing
myself
so you're not into holiday stickers and
tags that'll ruin your festivities
the holidays are so complicated for
everyone
we talked about this last year this is
our like year anna
they are wild anniversary anniversary
holidays are triggering a little bit for
some people that's true
well it depends on you know know that
we're working on not exaggerating that
wasn't that underexaggerating that's
my my new year's
what if i go the opposite way like no
one is don't exaggerate because then i
can't trust you
and i can't give compliments anymore to
people because everyone else exaggerates
so can we stop saying you're so amazing
you're
the best uh cook i've ever
if this is the best chicken i've ever
eaten it's like no
it's probably not yeah this chicken is
normal and you're okay
i just that's how we're gonna do coffee
because i when someone gives me a
compliment now i'm like
you say that to everyone and i'm trying
to give you a compliment
and my high school english teacher dr
abraham
who i hated at the time love now
she would go through my papers and cut
out varies
literally and said you never need to use
very and you never need to use literally
which i still use when i wrote my book
the note from the publisher was you have
literally in every chapter and literally
my favorite work
i hate you my new year's resolution is
to stop saying like
a couple episodes coming up y'all i am
sorry
i shapeshift to mirror my guests
it's an old habit that i and i'm on
antibiotics and steroids and dayquil and
like so many things for my sinus
infection and
i will we had a very young guest on
because i'm
young and she was saying like a lot and
i was saying like a lot and i was like
like
like you know and then she was like like
you know it was like an ocd festival
that no one bought tickets for
well i like that you're going to say
like less and you're going to stop using
varies stop interrupting when
when do you think that's going to kick
in i
only interrupt when 24 7.
i'm trying to help howard stern
was very clear in an interview when he
said
i interrupt people when i think the
audience is getting bored
because when i'm bored they're about to
get bored
so i interrupt if i'm bored and it
throws them
off there's a lot of boring people
coming up in here
my bad interviewer no i don't think so
you have a fast brain a lot to say but
it's not very fast
because very fast i didn't i would be
eating super fat
you never knew because i'm conscious of
it and i was like you need to use the
word super
very about extremely there's never
all right well then what are they why do
they exist remember the other day
you said can i be very honest can i
can i be more than honest no overly
honest guys you're honest or you're not
it's black and white
words we are defiling words
so when can i use very now you have to
tell me it is a word it does exist
very good is great very great no no when
can i use very
very great is awesome very awesome is
spectacular very spectacular is
stupendous
there's a word when can i use vary
because it is a word
it's in the dictionary very good it's
great
i will try i 2020 i'm going to try not
to use very
try and not use sorry always unless i've
did something wrong
um
i i would use it in a sarcastic tone
saying like
i'm very honored you're here oh like i
do little
you're a little dressed go do your
little thing it's like when you say oh
girl
oh girl this is how we talk in the south
who's we oh girl and generalizing's got
to go
didn't that pay for this house the at
first the first com first line in your
last special
everyone oh everyone hates me
yeah name names dragon i need date ben
and i got a huge fight last night
i need data last night
you guys are gonna think that all we're
doing is fighting i'm dating we end
every night with a good night fight
we do we have a night down i like to go
to sleep wake up angry
it's a download we download and i go
give me
feedback give me know it is a downer
that is true benton is like the only
person i trust i'm like tell me what i'm
doing right and wrong
am i going crazy am i ellen
i said it h.r i'm launching
investigation um
listen what what i need to go back
because we we skipped over christmas and
i was really excited to talk about
a tangent um what what else do you not
like about christmas
because i know personally i have some
christmas pet peeves too
i'm not i i enjoy christmas i'm a holly
jolly person on the year
and i'm sorry if this comes off me and
you know i'm a sweet boy
but i do need to say that if
you have multi-colored christmas lights
trash trash you get you don't ever need
him oh my god benjamin is your tree of
stop light
we're the same what are you doing have a
single color light you want all green
put all green you want to light me a
migraine
get all blue giving all women if you're
gonna have multiple life say better they
better fucking blink
they better blink it better be a disco
party
that insane to me insane inflatable yard
decorations
i will move i will move right if
done right the one down the street that
i posted on my instagram stories was a
snowman and the belly was a snow globe
and it was
gorgeous it looks like you have a car
dealership in the north pole
it makes no sense what is your house a
theme park
well when do you need a 20-foot snowman
a 20.
you gotta execute it well and it only
looks good at night is this the macy's
day parade
why does your house look like that this
is it right i know you think it's a
relationship
i know you think it's a really simple
way to decorate your house quick easy
and effective are you eating during this
i'm eating
yes okay um i'm sorry
i know you think it's a really effective
way to decorate your house quickly
it's not good it's not a fun time
i'd rather you get those little tiny
deer with the lights
they're just a silhouette of a deer i'd
rather see that than an eight-foot tall
dog holding a pressure
with a light and it would bubble it was
like liquid was in there
you had a lava lamp christmas decoration
and it was one string and it only had
like 20 on it so it was only like one
string you'd be like
you know what else wait i know you don't
like people um wrapping gifts in
newspaper
dude if you bring me i forget about that
if you bring me a gift wrapped in
newspaper
hear me out if this gets me canceled
i'll fucking
if this is the thing i will happily go
i know i'm a recycle person
okay i'm a recycle bitch
but i don't want to see the obituaries
on christmas morning i don't want to see
the
noopitals right nuptials right you don't
want to see
you don't see jobs job vacations job i
don't want to maybe you get a job by
this gift yourself
i don't want to see ads i read enough
ads on this show
i'm good if you're going to open your
bath and body works soap
paper bags from the grocery store
yes please add to cart don't ruin my
decorating yourself that's don't
ruin my tree i love your performative
lazy activism of newspaper
that's gonna get all over everyone's
hands true gonna give everyone a sinus
infection
you fuck why do you get you're all into
science fiction now you're like this
will do it i
hate you i'm pure and simple
you should get a one of those bags from
the grocery decorate yourself that would
be fun i would appreciate that also
in my family you don't
as soon as the wrapping comes off a gift
it goes in a trash bag
there is a aunt hovering at all times
holding a giant glad trash bag
just waiting it doesn't hit the floor
if it was a newspaper though you could
just lean back and read it
get caught up right you could open your
bath and body works candle and
you know we talked about the dominatrix
we talked about about the bodywork
so what are much other you know what
else
in trendy intangible gifts
don't do not don't buy me a star don't
buy me a planet
don't plant a tree for me don't do that
and if you're going to tell me first
because i don't want to get you a real
gift
and then you give me something i have to
a goat somewhere you got me a goat in
in oklahoma what am i supposed to do
with that
you got me a square on the moon yeah
don't do that
you got me a giraffe in africa right i
cleaned up the litter under this bridge
i don't use that bridge
but it's a crazy gift to get something
it's so funny don't ever do that
it's about the opening it's about the
joke gifts
no a whoopee cushion
a unicorn coffee giving me
don't if it's vintage i just
don't if it's vintage i want you
something people are like oh i got you
and it's like a
it's like a sloth-shaped ice cube maker
you put in the freezer
little sloth like this reminded me of
you why i hate this
now i don't think you know me now i
don't think we're very good friends
because this is the worst
i've ever seen the act like i like it
and then i had to like give it to my mom
and then she just had it at her house
i can't i can't i cannot throw things
away i'm a
self-diagnosed horse we can't be friends
anymore but i have to take this gift
because i can't look
and i got you a 40 candle yeah five
years ago i was in an allen on meeting
double winners
uh and the speaker said
my goal is to every year do half of what
i did the year before half the cooking
half the calling half the going to
parties half the gift as your friends
and family die
half the child every year i'll have to
give less and left if i make no new
friends
and i never get married or have kids
that's a great logic
so you have to kill your family members
so that you only have half everything
yeah
you don't give gifts anymore but you are
serial killers the trade-off but
invite them over to my house i think
it's worth it they'll get a sinus
infection from the construction right
you may be completely alone but it's
worth it to heal um so funny
it's like i mean but then it's true
people do give but it's a very
i give and it's my gifting one too many
a million not enough it's my drug
it's because it feels so good i wrote a
lenny letter about this you can google
the lena dunham letter thing um i used
to
give to people in a way that was so
grotesque with so many strings attached
i'm going to stream
strings attached i'm going to send you a
well that makes sense
network executive i'm gonna send you
like a hundred dollars worth of flowers
but why didn't you email me back like
it's always
what's your motive if there's strength
attached it's gross yes
they have to i'm gross you have to
receive it
the way i want you to receive it and
when i go to your house
bitch it better be on the table if i got
you a platter last year
when i come over that platter better see
this is where it's on you though
right did you get a platter that i like
because we talked about this
just get a registry i like i don't can i
give you passion
but it's about the opening it is i mean
but there's no better high than giving
someone a gift the feeling the feeling
of someone opening a gift
oh yeah my heroine oh this is my hair
it's great it's my heroine the guest on
the podcast today has four gifts
downstairs
some of them are things i love from my
home
that's a sickness oh
generosity is my drug
so i have to be more of a dickhead good
drug though
if you give me something with a price
tag on it just i'm
also don't give gifts shoot me in their
face yes with pride tags
tacky oh i also
um want people to text us to tell us
what guests they want to see what's
working and what's not working because
we're making changes to the podcast
studio
we're getting a new table i saw the wood
this morning
um no one will
you guys don't know that because no one
will check text on these chains that i
work so hard to make
um and we are
going to get we're getting wild guests
yeah um awesome the amazing shocking
we're also going on i'm star struck by
our guests
i mean me consistently but i need help
like i need
help with the curating because yeah
because sometimes you know
when you're booking guests like you just
we not whitney like
us just want to book guests that we're
interested in that we
find fascinating because that's why why
would you not that's how people's brains
work
so it's nice to hear like what you guys
think is fun or what you guys want to
see because then it's
more women more men it helps us balance
it out yeah like
they them hershey's i don't see gender
so i don't know
he him them y'all me neither my eyes are
always closed um
anything else before oh you had those
were your new year resolutions
right yeah we'll do that next time no i
mean that's what they are those are
right like
no i have lots more oh so many
yes i have lots more we're going to do
that next time
for the kaylee coco episode how many do
you have
i'm excited about this that's a litany
wow you have a busy year
i have a very diverse list
which is a litany very diverse just a
litany
very diversely still that's why i want
to do the word of the day but nobody
liked it so
um like subscribe
like subscribe comment share share the
videos we never say that
i don't think they're i think they tune
out yeah
don't share them and people are probably
listening to this wanting to hear
allison bree
or like skipping it yeah
and don't write elephants i say that
that's a good point you guys probably
aren't even listening three two three
no i'm sorry eight one eight two three
nine seven five two seven i'm checking
them
i post i repost them on my instagram i
respond
sometimes i take the wrong weed edible
and really respond to people
um send us sketch suggestions just notes
in general
if you hear this i love you bye
what's a good sushi restaurant hello
shalom fresh hola fresh hola fresh aloha
fresh
you know i love hello friends guten tag
i made a hello fresh meal last night
what was it i did it was uh the texas
mac and cheese that i liked
love love it don't even have to spice it
no there's like peppers in it i'm
obsessed with that it's so easy to make
i put some red pepper dried red pepper
flakes on i was like
yeah where are you changing their
perfect ingredients it's handled
it's very much handled hello fresh
healthy imagine if we had this
as kids how much taller it would be
hello fresh
it would say it would have saved my mom
so much work
how much stronger my fingernails would
be if i had
many less sinus infections i would have
if i actually ate
fresh food my eyelashes would be so long
hello fresh is great though it's a it's
a meal delivery kit that just delivers
pre-measured ingredients right to your
door they have like all kinds of meals
they have
uh meat options non-meat options they
have a calorie
option if you're like look checking on
your weight limitless
yeah i mean everything i mean and they
thought of everything
literally have everything and you just
it's super easy you can also do add-ons
like
garlic bread cookies bread is
i used to love olive garden garlic bread
but i think this is even better
sorry it's really good hot take i mean
this crankbait is great
i mean like at the cr those perfect
amount of crunch it is i mean it's
it's super they even have colors they
even send you a recipe for the garlic
bread that's just put in the oven at
if you have covered and can't taste i
feel sorry for you right now
because you can't eat the hello fresh
garlic bread
i think there's even kid approved
recipes now like in case you
have picky little kids picky little kids
yeah do you have some pillow kids i i'm
torn on that but okay
which one what having
and also hello fresh is committed to
giving back
in 2020 so far they've donated 3.5
million meals that's pretty cool
you can go to hellofresh.com good for
you 80 and use code good for you 80 to
get 80
off wow including free shipping that's
hellofresh.com
good for you 80 and use code good for
you 80 to get 80 off
including free shipping this is a new
year's resolution if i've ever heard one
how many times did you say it
one more time at least one more time at
least i have to tell you
one more that i attribute
most of my positive changes in my life
to ritual vitamins i mean
i do ritual is take your ritual way
before i had a podcast
you did you had rachel when i met you
you had it in your cabinet
ritual is not your typical multivitamin
rituals clean
vegan-friendly formulas made with key
nutrients and vitamins your body can
actually use there's no shady
ingredients most vitamins are
think about there's toxic shit in
vitamins
them out how is that legal dragon says
snatch their wig i will
i will not stop when i look at these
pills they're like neon pink and purple
i'm like why does that have
you just put food dye in it yeah it
cancels out the vitamin
this is a what a regular that's a that's
an instagram vitamin for aesthetic
i'm furious well
ritual has they just i think they just
started doing vitamins for men
and teens yeah oh good so now they're
not just for women i had these as a teed
they also have uh they now have their
best-selling prenatal vitamins nice
which is pretty important if you're
pregnant i'm going to take those and
just manifest
wishful thinking but also rachel the
climate ritual is that you have to think
about it it's delivered right to your
door every month
you deserve to know what's in your
multivitamin that's why rituals offering
my listeners 10 off during your first
three months it's my truth visit
ritual.com
whitney to start your ritual today don't
silence me on my own show
thanks for hanging out this long ritual
ready set go on you're a director how do
you start when you direct things
i'm like action but you're saying it
like a
old time i'm like action goal action
no you know what i think i had my first
ad saying action on the episode of glow
i directed
i was like you say action you're closer
and you can just yell it and then i
don't feel like these people i've acted
with
are now seeing me be like action like i
didn't want to be self-conscious about
the word unless i was standing close by
this is easily the most stressed out
about i've been about any interview
what the most stressed out easily me too
maybe but why you
but why you so
the most stressed out i called
i facetimed uh a brilliant director
leslie hedlund this morning to talk
about you
to like get a grip oh
because this is my deal with you
here we go everything about you uh-huh
i should be jealous i should hate you
my internalized misogyny should i'm
obsessed with you never
heard a negative word about you and i
don't
buy it is that true like a hundred
like that you led me in a way that i
thought something
terrible was gonna happen but and then
you said really nice things
bad things are coming oh okay i promise
okay good luck i'll keep the guard
slightly up even if i have to lie but i
was like
why is she so fucking
like likeable like why do i like her so
much it's because i keep myself at a
distance from everybody
so they don't i want to know about that
much the only problem i have with you
is that i think we should be better
friends you know
i actually often think that as well i'm
totally serious
because we have a lot of mutual friends
that's something that you would say do
you say this to everyone
no okay no in fact no no no
um like i feel like when we hang out we
have such a blast
100 i'm being totally honest and i do
not say this to everyone every time i
see you because we have a lot of mutual
friends
like i often always see you at like the
same couple people's
parties yeah yeah and every time
i get home and to davey i'm like i love
whitney he'll be like you know he'll be
like debriefing he's who'd you hang out
with how was the night
i'll be like you know i hung out with
whitney a lot i feel like i really
like her and then sometimes we'll text
yeah follow-up yeah exactly syria and a
year and so-and-so's next birthday
it's so we're such weirdos with each
other like yeah
and i think i mean i did think you were
a little mad at me at that game
party because i was very stoned and we
lost
our team was the lowest scoring team and
it was definitely my fault
i was mad at you i know i'm really sorry
i wasn't bad i wasn't it's impossible to
be mad at you
but i i i know i know i was like
sabotaging the team at game night at a
friend's house
and it was first of all that friend
tricked us all she didn't tell us it was
gonna be a game night until we got there
and at first i was like a little upset
but then i thought i was like that was
the smart choice because i might not
i get anxiety the prob here's what i can
get very competitive with gaming
but also i get a lot of anxiety so i'm
like let me just get stoned and have a
fun time and
curb my like intense gaminess and then
also i'll just have fun but
but whitney's mad at me was the downside
it wasn't i wasn't mad at you
i just the only bitch that's more type a
than you is me
and you're like b type a with me and i
was like not tonight you
invite me to a game night like i'm gonna
win the game night
i'm not you're already my friends and i
i will
happily lose a friend and win at a game
night
and see i guess and i've had some some
experiences where
i thought i was too intense in game
nights and so then i've been like i
don't
i'm the intention i don't want to so i
out intensed you
very much so because i drank the weed
lemonade which turned out to be much
stronger than i thought
that's right and then i also got the
word trombone for pictionary which i but
in my mind i was picturing a trumpet so
i was just straight up drawing the wrong
thing remember for five minutes
hilarious oh and then i felt
because i also am like i have allison
brie on my team
we're gonna be amazing the pictionary
game no one's smarter nobody's funnier
nobody's better at acting
like this but you were didn't go why i
was too high
you were high but it was fun for me can
i get sober breeze
i was mad at hybrid but not sober i get
that
um ironically i won a bottle of
champagne for being the worst player of
the night and i think that was a better
gift than maybe like the winning team
got the winning team googled the answers
and they lied that's true but the
birthday girl was on the winning team
who orchestrated the game night which is
a little like if you're gonna have a
game night why would you cheat but also
it's your night
and you're the birthday girl and also
i'm kind of pro cheating
what lance armstrong
i'm i ooh i did watch everybody cheats
he cheated the best
yeah i watched that dog and that was my
takeaway from it too
i was like i mean everyone was doing it
so he did it better okay so then
you and i i feel like i've carried
an embarrassment around you because
when you and i first started to like get
concentric and like know each other
you were on the really really cool show
community and i was on the really really
like
dorky sitcom show whitney and like
you were the cool like and i want to
this is not how
anyone thought of those shows and not
how i thought of those shows
um and i'm like i'm a loser
i'm a dork i had this whole narrative
i'm obsessed with like the way we
project onto people
yeah i projected so much onto you i was
like
they're the cool kids we're the dorks
oh mchale hates me uh does joel hate you
though
i i would if i were him why
i'm like joel doesn't hate anyone let me
tell you no it's the sweetest person
yeah joel and i
we had this conversation at the comedy
store like a couple months ago where i
was like i thought you hated me and he
was like
huh yes made it all up and he's like
do you need me for anything first of all
that's so funny to hear because when we
were on community i think we all felt
just like the
i don't know what what what's the truth
i was trying to think of somebody's
some awful cousin look i'm not firing on
all cylinders
i'm not stoned i'm just saying you are
the i feel like we were the bastard
stepchild
show on nbc but it's the quality not
quantity
you had the cool kids i mean i we
you were there i did feel like we had
good quality i loved working on the show
but also
it just like would never i would never
think of other shows and be like
we're cooler than that i think and i'm
not i'm not i'm not saying you weren't i
think i did do that to you no
okay i'm like except that one time i saw
you i forgot that i was like
i know for a fact because i do know that
my writer's room at the time
used to complain about your writer's
room's hours
oh our writer's rooms had it back
writer's rooms plural just one they had
it bad i don't think people understand
writer's rooms
like snitch on other writers rooms and
snitch on other shows and i know that
my show is the butt of a lot of writer's
room
jokes like inside jokes why in what way
because i mean i've talked about this
before it's it's no point in rehashing
it it was like a
it was like i was on all these
billboards and i was on this
chick gum and all right right
and i like was like on popcorn bags and
shit and it everyone was like
what it was like i would have i get it i
get it make fun of me
were you in the writer but you were like
there was a writer
there was a show called allison of
course you have a target on your back
this bitch totally of course so i was
like i was like
a punchline on snl
okay but wait two first question is
weren't you
in the writers room yes i was but so
that's different from like me
and the community writers my pocket this
is my biggest fear with you is you're so
this is what i call leslie about
i went uh allison is so fucking charming
and she's so smart she's so quick i'm
worried she's gonna run away with my
podcast
so then when did you start feeling
i was like swayed i was like don't let
her i i called her and i was like how do
i stop
allison from making this her podcast
that's a that what a funny question i
hope leslie only said nice things about
me because i adore her
and i've never had like i had so much
fun on that movie leslie
hedland sleeping with other people
directed bachelorette
genius she
i mean we talk shit about truly everyone
that i believe we sat on the facetime i
was walking
to my doctor and we're facetiming and
she we can't
i'm like why do we love her so like
explain what give me
some gossip what there's no one has
anything
on you i mean and this is why i didn't
think we could be friends originally
i was like number one i'm embarrassed
that she's on the cool show and i'm a
dork
okay i mean i i that was my projection
totally totally okay everyone i was like
i felt like carrie at the end of the
movie with blood um
i also always like i
couldn't i i only knew how to trauma
bond with people
okay and maybe it feels like i don't
have a lot of trauma i don't see a lot
of darkness in you
no there's not there's not a lot of
darkness which is so dark but i have
some trauma i mean like there's trauma
and horse when you did horse girl i was
like
yes her grandmother was schizophrenic
yeah i could talk to her we can be
friends now yeah
there's trauma in there but i would say
it doesn't affect me on a daily basis
mm-hmm you know you're just like such a
happy person and i i didn't understand
that for so long
sure it's not untrue but also and
and then i have like mild depression too
but
i don't know i don't know i don't know
how to talk about it and sometimes it's
really dark and most of the time it's
not
you know but it exists yeah what a dream
you are
it's so funny looking at you because um
i'm now like a fan
of yours like a like a big fan
because i've been watching i watched a
promising young woman
oh and it is and that's what made you a
feminine
three scenes of it you're like suddenly
it is a really cool movie it is a cool
i've seen it i saw it at sundance
it's when i got to see at its sundance
premiere
uh watch the rental i i i so i have a
lot of questions
sure i don't want to talk about the
movies i don't want to ask you any
questions that you've been asked before
great and i'm going to stop you from
talking even if you're being charming
talked about before because you're so
fucking charming even if you're saying
something charming and interesting i'm
gonna cut you off if it's something you
said before okay
so in the rental there was this
relationship
of this work wife work husband
thing uh-huh and when i was watching
that i was like oh
my that is my favorite sticky shit
like can men and women work together and
not fuck each other mm-hmm
sure where did that come from
um i mean david wrote it
very cathartic no no husband wrote it
yeah but where did that come from
because it was my worst nightmare
because to me so the the the movie
which i benton posted me watching it i
was like
i was literally like eating the screen i
was so
riveted by it
that's my the horror story started there
for me 100 oh i mean that's the horror
story
is the person that my
boyfriend works with yeah oh definitely
i mean i feel like
dave wrote it that way in terms of like
it's like
it's especially a nightmare for a
character like mine in the movie who is
like not worried about it at all
almost i think like that sucks more
where you're like i'm so confident i'm
actually not at all worried that my
partner's gonna cheat yeah
what fuck you um for letting me be so
quick it's so specific that
that moment when you learn do you
believe
that if you're cheated if you if you
cheat with me you'll cheat on me
oh well that's interesting but but i
feel like you're fishing for a story
about like
me cheating on someone with davey i'm
not fishing for anything no no i'm just
saying i
just feel like i'm i i don't have a
satisfying answer that's going to be
like oh i know that this came from
dave's experience with this i i mean i
do think he's
fascinated by that idea as well because
it's something i mean i guess
for us as a couple there's an
interesting thing where
we um
i feel like we try to always be so
respectful of each other in that way
because we're both actors and we have
like romantic scenes with other people
and so we want to be real open with each
other to be like don't
worry and i would never do that and then
of course
you hear constantly about other actors
cheating on each other who are in
couples
yeah and i i find it interesting that
like the way that dave and i react about
it
when you'll hear a story or someone you
know everyone's so fucking
you'll like get sent an article from a
catty friend who's like omg
look at this headline about this famous
couple
and davey especially if i ever will tell
him stuff like that
he's like such a compassionate person
and and you there must be some outlying
fear about that kind of stuff that it
more just makes him really sad and
bummed for the people he's not like
yeah or like oh we all knew about that
he's never
real um he's like oh no he's a real
outlier
yeah it's it's like and it's all true
you think i'm a good and charming person
i know right you guys are it's uh i'm
like i
i i have definitely been like
scientology
like there's definitely there's
definitely just i was about to be
i had a neighbor once who tried to rope
me in and i was like
you're always having the most fun you
think
i have a lot of fun it's the drugs you
have the so that's the other thing is
that you're you have a very healthy
relationship with drugs
i i do now i think i used to
uh like pre davey i definitely got too
drunk there was a like a period in my
life i think where i was getting
real blackout drunk like every time i
would drink
yeah and that was a dangerous it was a
dicey deal
no no and i definitely have like you
know there's family history with
alcoholism for sure
yeah are you scared of anything um bike
riding
like outdoor bike riding yeah yes
and you know oh you're just like
good no i'm scared of i'm scared of like
i hate to i don't know hmm i mean i
guess i'm scared there's definitely like
body issues
in my family so i'm scared of like
extreme weight gain
so which is a terrible thing to say i
love not a terrible like no no no no
i love every size of body and that's not
you know
this i will happily
get cancelled for this um you and i
used to work out together yes because
you used to train
yes jason jason i still do and yeah
that's okay okay there's no weirdness
there oh good
i never know i never i just live in a
mountain now that's true and i just run
up and down mountains
to us i just like um but
you're you you have this thing i have it
too
which is like you want to be
strong as shit yes and you're like
training for life
yeah and something wild happened to me
like
three months ago i was smoking weed last
year which doesn't
it didn't suit me at the time like just
like i don't like being slow yeah i
don't like being groggy
yeah it just doesn't work for me and
then um
i just stopped work i'm very i'm i'm a
very extreme person
i'm like working out every day sure for
two hours
and then not for six months sure it's
like it was like a weird pendulum swing
and then i started working out and i was
like why am i doing this like i'm not
training for a movie i don't even know
what this is for
and then my dog got really seriously
injured and i had to
carry him he's 120 pounds like to the
car like
and you could and you were like oh and i
was like i'm tr that that's why i was
training
like like i feel like you're training
for life bitch
definitely but that certainly shifted
with
glow became a whole new thing where i
was training for the job but then i
tapped into it
into like an even cooler way that i was
like oh this is really healthy for me
because i've always had weird mental
issues around my body
yeah and i've just about being strong or
fat fat fat you know
uh were you did you think fat was
fattening
yeah oh yeah i mean look all the stuff
like my mom did all the fad diets and
did all that stuff so i've like
everybody had like
i feel like we don't talk enough about
how our moms
always were dieting on those wild south
beach diet
well right all diet soda all of that
shit
yeah but then also we're doing like
there was the pre diet that was like
well i better eat a lot on sunday
because then i'm not gonna eat all week
and you're like what
like there's so for me there's a lot of
i've been able to watch
my mom kind of like try a lot of
different things that
seemed unsuccessful and then also watch
like my sister
like i have an older sister who's a
couple years older so like
then see the effects of it in her and
kind of how that affects her and the
different
it's like both of us trying to figure
out what's the healthy thing like i want
to kind of
change my brain so that i'm not
either there's like anxiety stress
eating
where it's too far you know and then
there's like
not eating which i could never fully do
the way that like people
girls in hollywood are like i just have
a coffee and then i'm fine till dinner
when i eat a big salad i would eat a lot
and then work out for three hours
sure and i may have gone through a small
phase of that sure sure
i'm familiar familiar with that strain
shout out to crunch
but like i think that strength training
was finally the thing that unlocked like
i feel like we all had this thing where
we were like cardio cardio cart like at
first i was like
if i just do a long run twice a day
then everything will be fine that's what
i'm hearing from you i think it's also
about like
we have so much fucking energy yeah
and there's also that there's also like
we have this energy and like i think
that
what makes you so great at being able to
be an actress and a writer and a
director like you
i think you're like what people think i
am
like everyone's always like you get so
much done and you're so productive and
i'm like
this bitch it swings the pendulum swings
i feel like i've noticed that like a lot
of shit happening you need a lot of shit
to be happening
i think that is true i think that's true
i also think
though i like a routine so like the same
way that you're talking about like
you're it's one or the other like i once
i'm locked into something
training with the trainer and i like it
it's working for me and that is clicking
in
everything into a healthy place of like
what i want what i want to say
is like especially once i started
training for glow and was like look i
mean i do want to
full disclosure i do want to get into
sick shape because i got to be naked
like fully nude for the first time on
screen yeah
and like i'd want to look good but also
i i've like agreed to do my own stunts
on the show and i want to
like do them for real and like just be
the best you know
um did you have the nude um i i
the last time i did a nude scene was a
disaster for a litany of reasons
but did they have the intimacy
coordinator not yet not yet we had him
by season three
there was someone that just hovering
around holding a bag well
in season three and season four
which because we shot two episodes of
season four that no one will ever see
but one of them included
you know a sex a topless sex scene with
me that no one will see i'm confused
okay so
i talked to jen houston about this the
casting director of glow
yeah they they basically shut it down
because covid
yeah sure yeah i mean look i think it
was
well yes fully so there's stuff shot but
not edited
yes so we were two weeks into production
we shoot six day episodes so we had shot
one
and almost all of the second episode
then the shutdown happened so we shut
down like everybody because of
kovid right then because it's a
wrestling show i think as people try to
look at ways to get back into production
our show was like just immediately
placed on the back burner like
obviously this will be a later show to
go back then
like the further it started to get
pushed uh you know some changes have
happened
uh managerially at netflix
i'm sure that people just started to
look at things and go
why would we continue to spend this much
like it was already going to be the last
season of the show
that it had already been a year since we
had since season three had come out
there's no one we started
anymore like it's gonna come back in
like four years right i mean you know
what i mean yeah you'll do like a movie
in four years like i just think i think
by the bell is out again isn't it yes i
just saw a trailer for that and i was
like
there are no rules anymore yeah you know
yeah
so it could come back but my point is
there was not an intimacy coordinator
for the for the or no no sorry that
there was an intimacy coordinator yeah
for the start of season four for my
topless sex scene
that no one else i have to be honest
with you it's like when you're
doing a sex scene with somebody it's
like already it's way more awkward to me
to have someone standing there holding a
bag being like are you okay do you feel
okay
it's like they started doing in um a
gynecologist's office
this was like a year and a half ago i
went to my gynecologist
and someone came in for the exam and i
was like i don't want that another
stranger it was way less weird when
there wasn't i was like do you need to
now i'm thinking about it that's like
you need to be here do you need a
babysitter
now you're just a gynecologist yes
lovely woman and no one else comes in
and i feel great
oh nice but here's i totally agree with
you
but i'm like who's who's you're the one
the
babysitter is the one that's dealing
with the trauma that's the person being
traumatized you have to watch someone
just finger me and i'm uncomfortable
like it's just like and we're just
making yeah i know
and like i'm like is this okay is this
okay but also
what's she gonna do she even if
something is
wrong she's not gonna get fired she just
wanna get fired right
i mean look i see both sides
i agree with automatic line of thinking
i would say
in terms of the intimacy coordinator
thing for me because
the ours came on in season three on a
sex scene on
hollywood actors a new thing is that
they shows will hire an intimacy
coordinator so for a sex scene
because that person will talk to both
actors that are involved and the
director of the episode they'll have
separate meetings with everybody
to gauge their comfortability with the
new situation
totally but we're finding i think in
terms of reports sometimes people sign
on they sign things saying i'm
comfortable doing nudity
and then they find themselves in a
position where they're not totally
comfortable with
it coordinator and i'm making less than
the guy that's fucking me
i mean look this is not
my soapbox what i want to say in terms
of being on your side
is in seasons three and four of glow
their thing would be we have an intimacy
coordinator and we'll check in with you
and like the joke with me is they'd
always be like
hey do you want that and i'd be like no
yeah because i'm with you i'm like
i don't i trust you guys but i can see
how
and i know that for some other women on
our show they did feel a lot more
comfortable
right there and here's a twist i'm numb
i'm not well here's a twist that you
might not have thought of because i
hadn't thought about it
one of the girls was telling me because
then of course i was picking everybody
to be like i don't know i always felt a
little responsible
as number one like on for the girls on
glow even though they were like fuck you
you're not
we're our own women but i'm like mom i
just want to make sure everybody's okay
so i would often so like in season three
i would check in with some of the women
to be like what was the meeting like
with the intimacy coordinator did you
like it do you feel comfortable
and one of the girls was telling me yeah
and
the cool thing well i think it had both
effects some of the girls were like i
don't know it was weird because now we
had to talk about everything way more
it almost made it more awkward but on
the flip side
one of the girls was telling me that she
advised her on like
body positions that maybe make your body
look
better like she was sort of like well if
i'm on top i don't want my
boobs to be like flopping weird and
she'd be like well arch your back more
if you're here
and in a way that's just a friend well
you might
just spend directors should be doing
that but if the director's like a man
that you don't feel
super comfortable with maybe you'd feel
weird if he was like sweetheart
arch your back more and your tits will
look better i can see
i can see the purpose of having one i
never wanted one
and i remember i did something with with
uh richard shepard um jenny connor's guy
did girls amazing and i was like i have
fake boobs
there's a little pucker here like a
little divot
can you please let me know and i'm gonna
look at the footage and just like let's
let's get it right i don't know i i
i just i'm not i'm not i'm
didn't get picked up for a lot of
reasons
um do you remember when i um
apologized to made a like apology to you
after we hung out
at lizzie cavlins um i do but
but why but also because i didn't i i
know i keep bringing this up but
i feel like i did text you to apologize
for the game night thing
like these are how our hangouts go we
have a blast together
we leave going that was so fun i should
hang out with whitney moore then two
days later we go
except i hope she's not upset about this
and then we text each other and every
time the other person's like i'm not at
all
i like love you like you would just say
yeah i was thinking it was great
what did you apologize for asking me if
i had gotten a nose job we're at a party
what no did i i mean you did what you
did
ask me if i'd gotten a nose job that's
insane
i'm so sorry i didn't apologize for that
no but i was glad you asked so that i
could tell you no
but i have it but my face has gotten
thinner as i get older and i think
people think i'm getting work
but i'm not i don't care things i've
worked on
i'm like i'm just getting older bitch
um not you i want to get better
i want to get better you know just the
thing that's on to this show
you know that song from the bleachers i
want to get
i like the bleachers i want to get
better help is that the remix
i want to get back well better help is
not a crisis line
so it's not self-help it is professional
counseling done securely
than online elitist people talking about
going to therapy
anything what knows you more crystal
water bottles
um what annoys me more than hollywood
people talking about going to therapy
as if noises lights as if everyone has
access to it
300 therapy in the middle of a tuesday
at nude
yeah not the middle of a tuesday that's
most most like hollywood celebrities i
know they go to therapy at like
4 15 on a wednesday in between
exercise and table reviews anderson yeah
well this is you can do from your you
can do wherever you want they're going
to match you
with a professional licensed therapist
you can communicate under 48 hours
under 40 hours you have to wait four
weeks to get in it's like i'm suicidal
guys you get timely and thoughtful
responses plus you can schedule weekly
video or phone sessions
so you want to sit in those
uncomfortable waiting rooms and you can
have you don't need to get a babysitter
so you can go to therapy
no this is on your time your time
wherever you can do it if you're sitting
in
you know a drive-through yeah yeah calm
on your lunch break
that's when you're do i that's the worst
do it from 9 to 10 a.m
when you're getting ready yeah dude at
three in the morning after you go to bed
visit betterhelp.com
whitney that's better help enjoying the
over one
million people taking charge of their
mental health with the help of an
experienced professional
take it away benton in fact so many
people have been using betterhelp that
they are recruiting additional
counselors in all 50 states special
offer for good for you listeners get 10
percent off your first month at
betterhelp.com
whitney you know what you have some of
migraines
migraines dude 15 years of my 20 years
of my life trying to figure out
why i had migraines and nobody's
migraines are alike it's
like snowflakes they're all very
different cove did not exist
when i was a kid it's really tragic
yeah you have to talk to your therapist
about it like better health therapist
no i didn't my thera i didn't no i i was
i would get cluster migraines i'd get
the pain behind my eyeballs
i couldn't see out of my left eye my arm
would go numb my leg would go numb
it was a nightmare yeah and that's not
how everybody's migraines are right
they're all different
so it's like you can't really take sugar
sometimes it's light exposure sometimes
it's sun sometimes it's stress it's
adrenaline sometimes it's coffee
sometimes it's not coffee
so people that suffer from migraines are
just like passing around like maybe
information like maybe this will work
maybe this will work and sometimes it's
you don't have the right prescription
for your eyes sometimes you grind it at
night i can do this all
well cove helps you get my lung relief
the migraine relief that you need all
online yes great
yeah you go to cove.com you complete a
quick online consultation and a licensed
doctor will recommend you a treatment
plan customized for your migraines i
also got these death piercings
but also you can get a pro they won't do
that but you can also get a
suggestion get a prescription delivered
to your door for as little as ten
dollars a month could work for cove
you think they'd want that yes i'm
quitting the podcast to work for code
she'll be writing this it'll just be 13
pages long
yeah you just take a few minutes of your
time and they'll lily plant it all out
for you and send it right to your house
like that's pretty amazing
could be from your sinus infection like
that i have go to cove.com
whitney for 50 off your first month of
medication with free two-day shipping
that's 50 off your first month of
medication
and free free two-day shipping with cove
dot com slash whitney
with cove dot com with cove
dot com slash whitney spelled with
w-i-t-h cove
c-o-v-e com
here's the thing with you that i'm
fascinated by
you are a biz nas woman
you think like truly and okay and here's
the thing
i'm fascinated by when a woman
wants things and wants to um get that
money and succeed
they're called ambitious sure and then
people go she's ambitious
and then it's like a nasty word really
like people
really see i love you i love you
the shame no shame you don't carry the
ancestral shame i have
that i carry like everyone's like
whitney's so ambitious like i always
heard that a lot uh-huh
and i always thought about you i'm like
she's so ambitious and fucking get
it bitch like i was like rooting like
i don't know why but you're one of the
few people that when you would get it i
would be like
instead of being jealous that's so nice
i know so glad okay but what did you
apologize for
like i wouldn't get jealous of you i'd
be like yes whitney
what what did you apologize for yes
ma'am um
we were at a party at lizzie's
and you were going to a
another party oh yeah of a producer this
is the same party where you asked if i
got
a nose job so it was part of the same
conversation at night
i was happy to talk about it and i um
i was you were like going to a party for
like a producer
and like yeah and i i see you as i
regretted it
i know i shouldn't have left that i saw
you do something codependent
and it triggered me it wasn't
codependent i saw you doing something
out of obligation
yes and is that is that codependent
because it was out of obligation that i
was like i feel like i should do this
you can't talk
but if it's a business move it was less
a business move and more of a like
i feel like this person has shown
generosity to me
and i should like pay it back by going
to this party for nothing
it's not generosity if i owe you
later i know
but what if i'm saying i don't know that
she feels like there's a scorecard but i
feel like maybe there is and it's the
polite thing to do
totally which is just and then
afterwards i was like i shouldn't have
done it
yeah no and i saw it and i got and i got
you were like why are you going to that
business i want to hang out with you
and i wish i had stayed and so you were
like i'm going to go to this party and
i'm going to come back
and i was like oh my god that's so
something i would do that's so some shit
i would do
well here's the other thing i had rsvp'd
to that party before i knew about
lizzie's
party i have a feeling if i had known if
i'd been invited to invited to lizzie's
party first i just wouldn't have gone to
that other
party at all just do whatever the fuck
you what do you want to do
but if you've rsvp'd to something
shouldn't you go no
why not fucking no absolutely not
i mean we're done i mean
my friends grandmother who taught me
etiquette
would be shocked no you changed your
mind
i'm like radically into do whatever the
fuck
you want to do cause can i do something
yeah are you here out of obligation
no i don't trust you now i mean
i don't know it's my nightmare that
someone would come to something because
they feel like they have to because they
rsvp'd and they'd rather be somewhere
else
i know but it's like imagine that if you
and i had exchanged your three
you don't want to be here at all no no
no oh my god no
she's a great actress now you get
anything i say you
box me into a corner good actress i
definitely want to be here
new hypothetical scenario about that
party
imagine if you and i had exchanged three
excited emails about me coming to your
holiday party and then i got an invite
to like
a better party and was like never mind
i'm not gonna come i'd rather go to
lizzie kaplan's party
that's so rude you don't have to say all
that you can just say hey i have to
sorry why kidding no i'm kidding i'm
kidding i would never say over sharing
no no actually oh you don't know anyone
anything though whitney
let me just tell you something
firstly i want you to know that
our friendship is not happening because
you go to parties you don't want to go
to
whitney i want you to know firstly that
i am in the part of my life where and i
find it very freeing where i
agree that i do feel like i don't have
to give people reasons why i don't do
stuff
and that i do find freeing and i always
i'm trying to give that advice to
younger people where like you know when
i was
younger i'd be like get invited to
something and then you'd be like
oh god um even like a friend and you'd
be like i'm so sorry i can't come to
your thing because
um i have my aunt's party and as if
as if they're gonna cancel it if you
don't or as if they're going to be like
so
like yeah it was all hinging this is
shit in the center of the universe
exactly it's way worse than just being
like i can't make it love you have a
great night
i just like was looking at you that
night and i was just like this bitch
has done i did not want to go to that
thing she's done it
she fucking she's writing movies she's
making movies
she books all the jobs she like sh like
this is it
this is your time to do what you don't
have kids like this is your time
to be radically selfish i know this and
i usually
implement it and that night i didn't and
i did regret it and it triggered me
i'm sorry to apologize i apologize
but but because here's what i was doing
i was roasting you with compliments
which is what i do i feel like you're
doing it to me now yeah i just correct
it's correct but i'm sorry why did you
text me to apologize
because you were giving me a hard time i
was like a party what are you doing
you're allison bree you don't have to go
to the fucking party
like i was like i wanted you my one of
my biggest like
third rails is when someone doesn't see
themselves the way i see them
sure or they don't see themselves the
way everyone else sees them but why do
you feel like you have to take that on
oh well i i trust me we all know we all
know why that
i don't want to be a fucking broken
record um
bad childhood but
and i felt so um
like shamey afterwards because i i felt
guilty because i felt like i was shaming
you
oh no when i was younger i was bullying
you you were like not wrong i was
bullying you to stay
and your friend uh uh julia
juliana juliana was with you she wasn't
with me yet i brought her when i came
that's right
and then you were like my friend wants
to go and i was like
well bringing up so much fun okay but
that's different that's like a close
friend and if she's having a thing then
i want to go
you know that's different that i think
is being a good friend no i i'm not
about to like not leave a party if like
my best friend we're both right
we're both we're both right okay okay
we're both right and yet only one of us
is raising our voice
so i have a this is just how i sound
talk i just yell i just honestly i'm so
loud too
and dave all the time is like you're
yelling at me i'm like
this is just the volume of my voice
honey you've married into this
it's too late i feel like there's
something so
interesting about you is that you're
like
i'm i it doesn't it hurts me to say this
i'm jealous
you're the most like fun like i've been
to weddings with you
she has a good time on the dance floor
love to dance
kills it in the speech everyone's best
friend not great at speaking
but i have fun no you a kill it kill it
kill it can't get along with anyone
i feel like i saw a movie that you were
in with lizzie kaplan
yeah and i remember being like
why did she get type or why does she
cast his like
type a bitchy like like uptight yeah
because i don't see you that way at all
no but you know
you might be uptight as a business woman
and that's a good thing
i don't know i don't know if i am what
what does that type mean together
on it why is that why why would that be
pejorative
i don't know i guess i feel like in
terms of the roles
like i do think for some actors
it's like do we i don't know i feel like
there are some roles that i can click
into really easily even though they're
different from me i'm like
oh it's like someone i know well
and i just it's easy and and i must have
like a bitchy looking face or something
where people just think
you're beautiful queen but
um i mean i have that side of me it's
just like
very low key but you know what it comes
out is like you know what i realized
recently
because i've been doing press but it's
not it hasn't been happening on this and
i was thinking i was relieved
because i feel like it'll click in when
i'm doing press for something and that's
when i'm very like
straight a student even though i was not
that i was never like a straight a
student which people wouldn't believe
about me i was like
no i buy it you know what i mean i feel
like in hi
i was just like you were there wasn't
even that you were the ran
no no no no no no i was like just in
between i was like having fun in drama
i was like cutting off all my hair
sometimes and then being like never mind
i was like really good always had an a
in uh
english class but i didn't read the
books but i was like good at
bullshitting like what they were about
i was touring once with a
one donald glover when he was a
community stand-up comedian
and a one-nick crowl and one chelsea
peretti and one
of doing colleges what a group i know
we were doing colleges for axe body
spray it was like a
tour we were i mean 23 24 on a bus
together
wild donald glover was obviously writing
music but he like had a website with
like furniture
remember when he had like a website that
was like with furniture he could for
like
things he liked it was like a style
website like this one
he was just i don't know if i do
remember that yes he was making
he had a website that was like um the
tabs
were like sex music photos like just
photos
of like velvet couches
photos of like whiskey i've blocked it
out this
community was you know my darkest black
out drunk days so i've killed a lot of
brain cells
fair but i've always been like hyper
sexualized and like i was just like a
pervy kid
yes like even though but like i'm
realizing more now in my adult life like
it was more on a superficial level than
i even realized like
now i'll talk to friends about like i
never was like masturbating
so in middle school
the library had two rooms
that you could reserve during like
recess
and lunch to do to do work i guess
and they were clear like clear glasses
you know i've known the story
and they've i've think about i want you
to tell it i think about let me tell you
i just want you know i think about the
story like a couple times a month so i
would reserve the room very responsible
reserve it for a certain day and then i
would invite some boys and girls to come
in
and put on like tlc and then we'd like
slow dance grind with each other and
after doing it like twice they were like
you can't reserve this room anymore
i was like well middle school so like 11
12. it's
wild i mean it is a wild
i just like dancing keith it was my hair
they're not that's not the nexium called
dances i like dancing you're just
of nymphat i just like dancing and i
like being close
with people yeah you know i um
watch the part of the reason there's so
many reasons i love the rentals and we
need to talk about your husband in a
second
but the rental it sho
you do everything in it whether you know
it or not thank you
it was like fuck you're funny in it
you're uptight in it
you're on ecstasy in it i've never done
ecstasy
oh really not weird yeah it's great but
i'll say that
at this point now in my life because the
last time i did it was to prepare for
that movie
yeah um and it was like dave and i being
like we haven't done it
in eight years since we like met each
other
and like let's do it again yeah and i
won't tell the story because i actually
feel like i've just been telling it a
ton
yeah um but but
the the the hangover like and lately
i've been much more into like
mushrooms yeah yeah i've not i've i did
lsd when i was 13
and then i tried to microdose that's
that's major it didn't go well it didn't
i'm not shocked it was i was alone
and it was like i was trying to be cool
with like
my sister and her friends and they like
just i was
what a drug to do and then i was alone i
was so neurotic
but i tried to do drugs i tried to do uh
mushrooms um
like a couple weeks ago and it just
didn't take it didn't do anything yeah
i'm too i'm such a workaholic
that i'm like i have to schedule my drug
use i do yeah i do that too
you know except during this quarantine
where i've just been like
it's been like my quarantine of
mushrooms because i'm like i'm gonna
write a script
like i i'm going into it with the
intention of like i need to break a
story
sure what is it okay so what's gonna
what what do you want that you don't
have
like you have like you want all the
award you're gonna get
but you're gonna get the awards like
that's fully happening
i mean no i i mean i try
to change my mindset since my cross with
being nominated for awards to to get
my head out of ever wanting that kind of
stuff but i guess i just want to do
fucked up it's a wild thing
yeah all that stuff is so weird and i
think that as like when you're coming up
in your career it's like such an end-all
be-all where you're like that's the
thing
would you want to beat meryl streep i
mean yeah
i mean i mean i i don't not want that
except the preparing the speech would
terrify me i'm so codependent like i
wouldn't want to win
like it's just like i you're i want to
be like it makes me shake even thinking
about it like the refresher
you then like saying do you want to beat
sandra oh yeah but it's not like you
can't be friends with someone if you
beat them
at an award show i yeah that's true but
we're
but actors act i mean are they acting
i don't think of it that way i just am
like i don't think carol's fine i don't
think everyone people beat meryl at the
oscars and she's like
cross that bitch off my list but it's
all so so she played my mom
in the post yeah so we acted together
and yes you know
so i would like to think that she
wouldn't hate me was meryl streep scary
she wasn't scary but like the idea
around her
like being in a movie with her was a
little bit scary like actually i was not
that scared of it but
like there definitely were some people
working on the movie who would be like
you're about to work with a legend today
are you ready
and i'd be like i mean i thought i was a
guy
why are you saying that it's way scary
to work with bad actors because then
you're worse well that's what i was
gonna say actually i was really excited
because i was like
i'm just gonna try to suck it all up
like yeah and see
are there any tricks i can steal from
merrell and just listen and react
i just want to know my shit like i've
never been more prepared for anything do
you have a strategy for your social
media
i don't know no i guess no
because because i think that i think
that there's this thing now
where actors
and part of the reason you're so
compelling and your talent is able to
speak for itself is because i don't most
people don't know that much about you
well i guess that's the one strategy
right i don't like
over sharing or overposting and dave's
real private so i don't i feel like
that's actually very helpful he doesn't
he's not i've we made
dave meet on two bro girls really yes
he came in on two more girls for the
role how do you do that you didn't get
the party no he didn't audition he met
he was a meeting only i think he was off
our own worse
i think he was offer only and he passed
based on the oh good i was like based on
the meeting he didn't get it
you know what that's this is the end for
us he was just such a charming
like i feel like you guys are like the
next will and jada he's just oh wait
that's probably
like well minus the entanglement
sorry i like to think of us as the next
uh mary steen virgin and ted danson
okay okay mine is the black face look
look
there's there's controversy everywhere
it can't be avoided i just worked with
mary on happiest season and she is
the loveliest loveliest person i've ever
met and seeing the two of them together
i was just like
oh yes yes watched it loved it watched
it not only that i don't know if i'm
allowed to say this
watched it facetime dan levy and he
watched it through my facetime because i
had an advanced screener
and he hadn't seen it seen it so he got
to see it for the first time i mean
not the best way for him to see it for
the first time but i like that you did
that
i love it i think it turned out great
it's so like
it was um scrumptious
yeah it's a scrumptious movie yeah and
it was weird because at first i was like
uh but i have to watch
like is it lesbian like am i still
and then i i forgot it was about
lesbians it was just about human beings
yeah
it was about everyone's family oh
totally i actually i think it's much
more about
family i mean i what am i gonna say i
like the headline because it is the
first
you know uh studio-backed holiday
rom-com that
stars a gay cup that features a gay
couple that it becomes a headline but
like
i think the movie is like an amazing
holiday movie about a family where
everyone's flawed and everyone needs to
learn think it's about that it's a good
movie is the headline
i mean even better like i was just like
why are you guys making sure that it's a
lesbian movie like who can like it it
just feels like it's
i think that made me go like oh are you
gonna like preach to me i'm already on
your
team and then it doesn't i love it
because
it felt like notting hill to me oh great
i was like although
i was like this is like the next
nottingham hill like scrumptious
yummy i love every character every
character in this movie i have a family
member that's
like them that's my sister that's my mom
that's my aunt that's happened to me
we've all
like totally and i also feel like i
should say
that as much as i love notting hill and
i've i i've been watching it for years
think it's the most sexist movie ever
made but that's another
well watching you recently not even
sexist but i was like
yeah it's a tricky one the message is a
little strange throughout the movie
where it's like
she's famous so she's better than you
but also it's not
movies jobs to send the right message
you're right i truly don't think people
go to movies
for value education no i agree but at
the same time when you watch it back
aren't you a little bit like
do i hate her character i'm sorry i just
watched mine hunter and loved it
i watched the ted bundy tapes why when
it comes to comedies
why when it comes to comedies do we why
everyone has to be likable this is what
i'm obsessed with
i'm obsessed with now everyone wants
like like on earth like
problematic movies like friends was
problematic
sure it's so funny because you're so in
inside this
with me that it's like we know the
people that write and direct these
movies
yeah they're all insecure people that
are just trying to get approval from
their parents that didn't give them
enough love
so they're writing these fake stories
that they've never experienced either
the fantasy they want because they just
want to get a movie made
with katherine heigler sweater spoon
sure and it's absolutely unrealistic
because they've never been they were
dorks in high school
that didn't get love and then people are
going fuck you guys for creating these
impossible standards
like well but they don't it's creativity
it's coming from everybody's
individual brains and let it be their
self-expression
what i will say just to bring it back to
happiest season and
what i find to be so great about it is
that it has all that scrumptious like
holiday fun visually just like it it's
like
drinking hot cider but also but also
the performances are great like i think
kristen like obviously kristen stewart's
amazing and mckenzie davis you're like
this is this is what i like i forgot
kristen stewart was kristen stewart
which is very hard wow very hard to do
did did you forget i was me i
it's this is why i think you're that i
because i was watching promising young
woman which i do want to
discuss i yelled me and leslie hadn't
screamed about it
uh this morning um it's cool it's
uh i i need to watch it again it's like
one of those movies i want to watch a
couple times yeah
it's really hard for me because i'm like
when i watch my friends acting i'm like
do i are you a better actor because i
know you or or a worse actor
like yeah are you so good that you're
overcoming the fact that i know you like
it's just
a mind fuck i like this you are so
fucking good in it
thank you it is such a fun
part i hate when actresses say that
don't say that don't say that
it is a fun part it's i got to be like
kind of like what you did was
so hard what you did in what way
because i you had to be
um uh because you got to keep her
redeemable in the end
don't even like that what does that even
mean you had to like
be a no like this kind of
um high strung full of shit
super smart girl that made a mistake
that was carrying guilt
like i had to feel that you were guilty
yeah
i had to feel that you were fucking it
was all subtext
thank you oh this is a great compliment
yeah no i know
finally we got to one it was like i was
just like dude i
i'm buying it i felt that way
i buy this shit and
it's so hard to put it's so easy to put
too much icing on the fucking cake with
a part like that
and then it gets cartoonish well you
know i think it was helpful
like this is a character that had a
secret and
sure you know well but also just like
that kind of
it was a interesting year in terms of
like the order in which stu
i shot all these movies that have now
all come out this year yeah yeah
you you you might do too many movies
it the most movies i've ever done i did
last year and now
2020 has been like my big career year
i'm like
oh good the world's on fire this year so
more people are watching movies than
ever but it's like
but it's like i don't know why i'm not
sick of you it's weird
well the movies are all very different
like the genres are different and also i
don't have
i'm not like the big part yeah in most
of them so
fucking um thank you i was gonna say
that the rental was the first of these
movies that got shot right so i shot the
rental
a month later i shot a really horse girl
uh
i guess actually maybe promising young
woman was the first thing i shot that
little part
what was emerald fennel like the
director promising young woman first of
all she was
super pregnant while we were shooting
which already i was just like whoa
yes i was just like so impressed by her
um she was just so great she was
succinct in her notes
she was complimentary she was like all
the things she was commanding in a way
that i was like
i trust you and like i'll do whatever
you say but you're not saying too much
to me
no oh really what would i have from the
i mean she's friends with our friends
at the world at the italy wedding we
went to that's right
no i don't know if we even met that
weekend yeah that's what's weird
actually
you know always gets a little weird yeah
no i didn't know her so that was
good well we have yeah obviously mutual
friends so it's lovely
now what you have five i'm sorry you did
you did it dude i like i knew you i knew
you
when you were just like a scrappy bitch
like yeah testing for community and
you're like allison brie got like
i remember it happening i remember it's
like bree bree bree and then all of a
sudden like because we had a lot of
mutual we had some mutual friends even
then i feel like that's why we're on
each other benny and then i was like
this bitch is just going and going and
then
like two years ago we're at um jessica
albaum's house and you're like i'm
thinking about writing this movie about
this girl on a horse
and i'm like here we go and i just want
to write a movie and i'm like i have to
talk about
horses for two hours with her and
nothing's ever going to come off you
loved talking to me about it and then
like
eight months later it's like at sundance
i was like this bitch
that's crazy well that's a jeff bana
thing i feel like i got i don't want to
give the credit away because like i'm a
woman and
like fuck yeah yeah women yeah but like
bane is a great partner because it's
true he really is like a force in terms
of just like keeping something moving
thank you jeff no one knows who you are
so we're not going to talk about you too
much sorry
well i mean i'm just saying though he
really was like at moments where i'd be
like
oh we wrote this thing but maybe i i
might be able to do this other part in
this movie so we should put that on the
back burner because who knows if we'll
ever get it made he'll be like
no we got to commit we're going to shoot
it in june just tell your agents that
yeah and then we'll just like make it
happen i was like
okay what do you want that you don't
have i mean
i just the thing is that don't you
realize that the more that we work
there's not ever uh you made it like
that's like
then you're like what's tomorrow i gotta
keep making one like
not enough so it's like i think at this
point i actually feel
like i had a moment of like oh
you got close to some things but you
maybe you're never going to get like
all the things and that's okay because
you just want to do good work and keep
making your work and then that's the
thing i want
yeah you know like during quarantine
yeah you wrote a couple movies i want to
make those
you like love what you do you love it
yes
that's what it is like you don't have a
you also are
you also really are good with people
thank you i actually agree i know i did
good
i actually agree my fans no i feel like
you can get along with anyone which is
part of the reason why i think you're
going to take over the world because
like
i quarantine i'm thriving so hard in
quarantine because like
exchanges with people is are so
exhausting to me it's so
hard for me sure you're so easy to get
along with
oh i just like i shouldn't have said
that that was stupid is this person mad
at me like
the amount of bandwidth that's taken up
just by like dealing with people is
exhausting to me
sure but i like people i know
i like but but i i think i think where
that's shifted
is like i think directing has helped me
realize
that this is a big good strength of mine
i guess in tv in tv i always wanted to
direct because i've worked in tv for a
long time i worked on these three shows
on community i always like wanted to
direct i think just because i
saw other actors directing on tv it was
like yeah and also we'd
once you're working on a show for so
many years you're like i could direct an
episode of this show like
how hard is it that's literally like
right where you're a little bit like
direct is like i could just let me do it
because i feel like i'm landing here
yeah but then i did it and it was like
crack a little bit where it was like
one pick your takes and not just that
it's like it's like selfishly fun to
like discover a new skill
like it is fun to go oh fuck i might
like i'm kind of good at this
yeah i'm a little high off of just
knowing that i am dude but i also good
at it
like i just i don't know hot take like i
also think like
women shouldn't have to direct if they
don't want to well
of course there's a thing now that's
like every actress is like has to direct
it's like
you don't have to like no no no no no
do you know what i'm saying it's like
you're born to do it
i love it and i've had and i so i also
just directed
i just feel like we feel pressure to
have to direct because of this
numbers thing i agree which is like now
you're
i thought the old me too is don't do
anything you don't want to do now i feel
like i'm being forced to direct and i
don't want to
no i agree i had a moment too of being
like
of having like a weird identity moment
where like my character on glow
is like supposed to not be a very good
actress and then it's like she's
excelling in directing
and then i was going to direct an
episode and then i had a moment of being
like
is it because the universe is telling me
that i should direct because i'm like
not a good actress
but like actually my passion is still
more in acting than
directing but i like directing but like
i'm not yet at the point
where like i would take a directing job
over a cool
acting job whereas like dave might be
hovering on that point like he excelled
so much
directing and loved it i i i i he's like
i think i like that better i
actually you i used to be a very like
it's not the director it's the dp like
once i
like once i directed a movie i was like
oh this is all the dp in all budget
and then when i watched uh the rental i
was like
oh shit i mean like he's
a good team he's like on some new shit
if you think i'm type a and a hard
worker like
dave dave makes me look just like a
chill stoner wife
he made some choices that were just and
i and i know that it's like hard to
articulate why a movie is good but
to watch a movie with a bunch of people
that i know and i know the director
it's like not well but like i it was
the choices there is this one
scene yeah what scene spoiler alert
i'm gonna say i don't know it came out
in june so um where there's a dead guy
on the side of a fucking cliff and they
can't get him down
and they throw a rock and it hits his
head and just like like
who like whatever it's so funny but it's
like such a dark moment
the funniest darkest like i literally
was like
this motherfucker like it was so
surprising and so like ballsy and
it was cool um shocking
it was cool dave was so specific as a
director
like crazy it was you know there was it
was a little
there i i i don't want to exaggerate i
really hate exaggerating and
i'm i i wanted to um
like there were some neil labute vibes
yeah
who was easily like my favorite
playwright
amazing and there were kind i even wrote
stuff down
and there were some carnal knowledge
vibes in there oh
okay the major way okay you know like
we're just gonna watch
this really seemingly mundane thing
happen with a tremendous amount of
tension almost like the gaspar noi like
irreversible
oh i'll never forget when i watched that
movie and then it was this was so long
ago and my boyfriend at the time
like we went back to his apartment i was
like we cannot
have sex tonight or for a while like a
while
and he was like oh for a beat we're
going to take a circle back
he's like are you okay i was like no no
that changed the way that i
saw i mean he changed my relationship to
like time and spit like that movie
as traumatic as it is to watch um but
yeah i was
unbelievably impressed and i don't like
scary movies
they yeah i don't like magic and i don't
like scary movies i don't understand why
i like
magic at all it annoys me that i don't
know how it's happening
it just frustrates me i have to pee now
okay yeah i knew it
i heard that you don't want children
i knew we were going to talk about this
and i'm so
glad we don't have to no you know what
it's it's
i do want to talk about it because it's
something that normally i'm annoyed to
like so annoying i have a journey the
worst i have like
such complicated feelings just about
even the idea of talking about this but
not complicated feelings about
not having children does that make sense
yes um
so on the one hand like the fact that
i'm asking it what a
dickhead i was gonna say there's the
classic like you know dave and i are
doing press to get like for the rental
and we're doing the same interviews with
the same people like him half an hour
before me
and they'll ask me but not him you know
there's that classic thing where i'm
like
well we're in a marriage together like
do you want to claim it's the same thing
i don't know i guess it'd be weird thing
to ask a guy
but it's like if you're asking a married
couple oh you guys are married
why wouldn't you ask the guy are you
guys gonna have kids yeah yeah yeah yeah
that doesn't to me i think that's
i don't yeah but they were like
they know what they know people are
interested they know that's what's
here's the real mix thing is that part
of me is like
it shouldn't be a big deal that i don't
want them so why is it something i get
asked about so much
and then on the other hand i'm like well
i guess there have been some women who
have
like that like in person have been like
oh i think it's great you don't want to
have kids like to me it's been such a
stigma and it's really refreshing to
like hear you talk about it yeah and
then i go like
oh good i should talk about it but then
there's also been
i think in my journey of you own nobody
anything
no totally in my journey of talking
about it
there's also been those funny things
where like for example
the first time i talked about it it was
one of those classic things where
ah it's not like i was planning on
i mean i've never wanted kids but it was
not one of those things where i was like
i'm gonna drop it it's now i'm coming
clean about like not wanting kids
so i offhandedly in an interview i had
been so
uh do you ever do interviews where you
you know they're going to ask about
something dicey
so you're like uh you don't get asked to
do the stuff you get asked
they don't bother with me well i was
doing some interviews and it was just a
time where
there was there were things going on
there were like things i definitely
didn't want to talk
about so my guard was up for those
things like throughout the whole
interview yeah and then at the very so i
think the even she could tell because
she kept trying to like corner me and i
was just kind of skirting it
yeah and then offhandedly at the very
end of the interview she was like well
like
what's up with you and dave like do you
wanna do you think you guys are gonna
have kids and i was like
no seems like a lot of work like as a
joke wait can we tell you something
really quick
the fact that you're doing you don't we
don't get paid for press by the way
right the fact that you are going into
an interview
with someone who's trying to get you i
mean
we're not getting like all those
annoying fucking interviews that on
access
we don't get paid to do press yeah
that's so stress it costs
us money to do press because you have to
pay for the stylus of the makeup art
this is the shit that i don't understand
why people are talking about this shit
well what bothers me is when for the
last 30 seconds of an interview i go
like
not really seems like a lot of work and
we laugh and i leave and then the
headline is like
allison brie opens up about not wanting
to have kids slams kids
and i'm getting texts from my mom
because i've always who cares i have the
same
i've always i'm always like kids seem
like a lot of work i don't think i
mean i was just making a joke first of
all that's not like if you were really
delving into like so the reason you
don't have kids yeah i mean
that's not not the reason but i'm just
curious because i'm like at this point
i'm just like
i'm yeah inspired and fascinating no i'm
not you're not brave
i'm not no no no oh my god no i don't
think i am i feel like honestly the
other side of it is
i've been like well it's not something
that defines me and then this year
even two days ago to dave i was like i
guess it does kind of define me because
everyone i know is pregnant currently
i'm like i mean honey if we wanted to
have kids like
this would have been the year we would
have done it like i mean we don't
making a movie i know that moms are
gonna come at me for this but like
it's it's kind of a similar experience
it's nine
months of hell and then you sure put
this thing out in the world
and like it's you don't sleep for six
months reading the reviews and doing the
prank you know it's it's like a
very i haven't really experienced that
but that's certainly what it was like
for dave
with the rental and i was like uh
no i mean like because i didn't direct
it so it was like a whole different
thing to witness like oh wow this
journey like
is so intense making a movie is just uh
you know
yeah sure i think it's like i think this
is why it's funny for me to talk about
it because there's not
like what's the stance the stance is
like i don't know i never really wanted
to
i've just never wanted to and i still
don't and that's like it's such a
like why do we have to pathologize it
but what's more interesting to me
is that you found someone that had the
same point of view
it's insane and trust me i check in
constantly
because i was like oh someone's lying
someone's lying to the other person
and it's gonna secretly go what the fuck
i thought i thought we were just saying
that because we were saying it
i know i check in constantly two nights
ago i was like
babe you really you really don't want to
have kids and i asked it in that way and
he goes
what now suddenly you want to have kids
i was like no i don't want to have kids
i'm not sure you still don't want to
have kids
he's like i don't want to i was like
great so
we check in with each other every time
especially lately as like
in the past couple years as friends of
ours are starting to have kids
yeah so then we go and there are those
moments of like i'm looking at my
husband like
rock a baby and it's adorable yeah and
i'm like
nothing yeah i feel okay and then we
leave and i'm like
how did that make you feel are things
moving and shifting yeah it's like
no are they with you and i'm like
freezing eggs nope
no not bluffing somebody was like you
should freeze your eggs i was like
why would i do that if i don't want to
have
children yeah yeah yeah it seems like a
lot of work for something that i
probably don't want to do right i yeah i
get the boating license i don't have a
boat but it's like
you're like i know i trust me that's the
other thing i get a little nervous about
talking about it in this way and then in
three years i'm gonna be like what if i
wanna have them now and everyone's gonna
be like what because
you were the face of not having kids and
now you're having we've been so
trained to believe that we're gonna come
to our senses
that we're gonna change our minds yeah
mine happened
when my dad died i was like not having
kids but mine was more like i don't want
to
like keep duplicating these
um genetics like i don't want to like i
want to just yeah
that's the line that might be part of my
thing like the line stops here i don't i
don't
um uh i don't wish this on anyone sure
sure
yeah just like like stop the bleeding
yeah um
and then my dad died in some primordial
like
yeah like i gotta yeah make one of those
but for me it's my deal is i
want to have a kid with the right person
and i don't want to have a kid with the
wrong person
so i'm like well i just don't want to be
stuck with somebody that's whack
i mean trust me i think about that
factor because my parents have been
divorced since i was five but like
they celebrate they have to celebrate
every holiday together with with each
other forever
yeah like and i'm always just like i you
would like to think that dave and i will
be together forever so it's like really
not that's not the headline with dave
specifically but like
i'm sure just in life in general it's
informed part of that for me where i'm
like woof
then it's a lot you're really connected
it's like much deeper than
being married to someone is having a
child do you dave ever run out of shit
to talk about
i mean not me i talk constantly he's
always like he'll be not talking and i'm
like
i thought of five more things to say
he's like okay
like i'm just so fascinated by like how
like i remember there was some story
um i think you told me about how you
guys were like in ojai like or like out
of on a vacation or something i was just
like
god like i i just i i obviously i love
being in a relationship i love being in
love but there are times where i just
like need a fucking like three days off
sure well i mean just because i'm like i
don't i feel pressure to entertain you
like yeah what did that mean like
this door slam was that what was that
like there's a lot of like
yeah you guys can just co-exist yeah
yeah yeah
you can walk by each other down the
hallway and there's no like you good
yeah yeah yeah you walk but there's all
the
i mean i mean walk by each other in the
hallway like you sound so
funny either without saying a word no
what do you say like hey what's up i
don't know i'm trying to
like visually picture us like if you're
passing each other in the hallway
i probably like give them a little kiss
or
like during the day grab grab him i
don't know like a
high five i don't think we would ever
just pass each other and not say
anything i don't understand
couples are so weird to me it's so weird
that you're just in the same house like
doing things and not
like yeah yeah that's how do you it's
hard for me to be in a relationship with
somebody and not be thinking about them
constantly
if they're like they're yeah i mean
we're able to
not think about each other constantly
we're able to do that and then also
there are some times where i'll be like
honey two hours ago i felt like you said
this thing to me weird yeah did you
uh-huh
and he's like no i didn't mean to say it
weird yeah
but you're not in like therapy no yeah
but
but dave is such a healthy person i know
it's i used to have
trouble i used to be he's so healthy and
sick
it's insane like on every level i'm like
you never like
drink too much i don't get it i just
like it no i drink the perfect amount
until i feel the way i want to feel i'm
like hear me
what normie yeah and he had a very
healthy
upbringing too great mom and dad and
like but like
with communication i've gotten so much
better at it
being with him even though it's not like
he's the greatest communicator but
because he's so
like such a safe person yeah like i used
to be
much more passive aggressive because
that's what i saw like
my mother do of like nope nothing's
wrong that's always any question
two weeks later being like ah my
question is like
are is it me or is it you me
with you so it's like i
recently moved out to like the middle of
nowhere yeah
and i was like oh i'm not as crazy as i
thought i was i was just
in like a rigmarole and it was like
adrenalizing me and making me manic
and there were times where i was like
was i crazy in that relationship
or was just you brought it out it's like
yeah he brings out the best version of
you yeah he really does
and i think about that too with x's
where i'll go through people and be like
well because you know with an x you'll
go through a phase where you're like it
was all them
yeah yeah yeah like as soon as you're
out which i think is a healthy thing
depending if it's like you should be
getting out of that to do it yeah
relationship and you need that thing to
sort of separate you
and then years go by and you're like
and also i did this and then i feel like
i landed a happy medium of like
well we just kind of weren't that
compatible with each other and we're not
bringing out the good parts of each
other like i feel like you don't have
any enemies
i thought i bet i have a couple like i
just feel like you don't have any
beef like there's no i bet there's a
couple people have
beef with me but i don't know
i don't know why but i'm sure they do
yeah but that's their problem
yeah i maybe i used to have some beef
with people like i don't even project
onto you
well i just separate this is what you're
saying i separate myself from people
that i feel like
i don't like so then i don't have beef
with them because i don't
interact you know how to just keep i'm
like oh that i don't want that person in
my life
if someone's gonna i'm the opposite if
someone is like toxic or
i go entrench with that person sure to
get their approval
shape-shift and become their soul mate
yeah so that they can't hurt you and
then it's a just
rat fuck shit nightmare i don't do that
no
no no that doesn't sound that's clear
i don't like that
don't recommend it i don't i don't don't
try this at home
you're very good at like bobbing and
weaving
sure avoiding toxic shit i am like a
moth to a flame with toxic
people yeah i'm trying like mentally
trying to go through my mind to be like
is there any work story where i like
really couldn't work with a person but i
don't know if there really is
i mean there's like one director of an
indie movie that i know i was really
hard on and when i think back about it
i'm like
i was kind of a bitch to him but it's
because i felt like
he didn't know what he was doing and he
was like a kid and he hadn't directed
anything his parents had a lot of money
yeah i was like the lead of the movie
and i'm like and i got real
nervous yes sir so i had to be like no
you need to do the job better yes and
then he would pull me aside but he was
so much because no one cares about
i i i like a poster when someone's very
meek then sometimes i am a little like
yes
don't be so meek like i need you to be
stronger
especially if you're directing me you
know what i mean
so i feel like i was a little bit into
that yeah that it's like
and also you were number one on the call
sheet and everything was
fed into it and it was already like a
weird movie like i'm taking a risk and
doing this weird thing but i think it
could be cool
wait a minute i don't trust you at all
like i got a hold of the shit
i'm scared and you're not being in
charge enough yeah
but then that's something where i'm like
i still try to learn more about that
we're like
i don't like being like that so you
gotta i think you had to do that
in the moment it did feel like i had to
be that way and now i wonder is there a
way i could have done it that might have
been a big
kinder no i don't think so it's like i
remember one time
i had to fire someone yeah and i could
not do it
it was so i i like firing people is just
i agree
it was my nightmare i had to fire
someone i hate
and then finally someone phrased it to
me in a way that i could
understanding what he was like this is
gonna help
them yes they're gonna learn
sure i think that's how i felt with that
person where he would try to take me
aside and he's
shaking and he would be so nervous and
be like um i just don't appreciate the
way you're speaking to me in front of
the crew and i would say
you need to hear me speak like this to
you you should be speaking like this to
me to me exactly i'd be like
i need this from you you have to raise
your like you need to be louder
you make me nervous that i don't know if
you're because you believe in your
choices or jumping off cliffs
and you're like i saw something that i
loved um um
it was me in a little bit though um no
but you were scared
every anger is always fear sadness right
always totally unhappiness i've been
around some people that i'm like that's
if i think about beef from like 10 years
ago or people that in my mind i thought
i
hated yeah for a while and now i'll be
like i don't hate that person they were
so
unhappy when i was working with them
they were like they hated their body
they were jealous of me because of this
or even not even about me it wasn't
about me at all it was just like
they were unhappy with this this and
this and i can see it from afar and i
feel for them that they felt that way
but
it sucks that they made everybody around
them miserable but i forgive them
like i get it yeah that's so interest i
just gets
i get so fascinated by that shit of like
yeah our ability to tolerate the
discomfort of others
yeah and like how like i
like i'm kind of taking a break from
like tv and all that stuff because it's
just
it's it's watching it just i don't watch
a ton of tv oh
i really i know i'm that bitch i'm like
a hipster
and you're trying not to also like write
or be in working in tv like i just it's
just like such a
the business is changing so quickly and
i think that yeah
i've been so rode hard and put away wet
by this business like this machine
yeah and i there was so much um
sick shit going on with me in this
business of like
daddy daddy love me love me sure and the
approval seeking
and the um
like when you're writing a show or or
running a show
or directing a movie like you're not
being an art your business
it's all you're you're right it's it's
especially running a show
do you do you think you're running a
you're an accountant yeah
and it's like all you're doing is giving
people bad news
all you're doing is telling people all
you're doing is telling people they have
to stay late all you're doing is telling
people they're wrong it's like
you're the bad guy yeah and all i wanted
was love all i wanted was
like i did this because i want to like
entertain people and make people laugh
and now everybody hates me and i want to
yeah you know what i mean
yeah i just like i i have very low
tolerance for that
yeah interesting and i'm like seeking it
i'm like and i'm trying to like
produce more tv i'm like trying to put
myself in a position and do that but but
i haven't done it yet just don't just i
think the thing is with tv is like just
don't
involve a lot of people do it as much as
right and like but
how don't you it my thing is hire the
best person let them do their job
yeah but like keep your circle small
yeah yeah yeah
good advice it's like does that make
sense like crews don't
i'm not encouraging not employing people
but it's just like
there's too many uh we all recreate our
childhood circumstances when we get in
this hierarchy like when there's
an authority figure everyone you turn
into everyone's mom everyone's
alcoholic dad whatever and then it just
turns into this projection festival and
then it's just like
by the time you get on camera you're
just like
like by the time i leave the makeup room
like zoe lister jones and i talk to
direct something and then act in it or
to show run and then act in it i can't
imagine that
sounds like but also why like there's
also a little bit of like a lot to do
no one else can do this no one else can
direct it right
you have to write it and directed at
like no way and star in it and starting
it
and editing yeah yeah no one else is
qualified
like so let them i have to just like
look at myself and go like okay am i
being an addict am i
mothering martyring micromanaging am i
trying to like prove something
like yeah i would you know yeah yeah i
get torn it depends on the project
but my thing now is um
i don't want to
uh things to take a long time to make
yeah i don't like unnecessary byzantine
steps of like
the notes in the doom and yeah and like
there's a l unfortunately there's a lot
of fake jobs
and i'm not i'm not
advocating to get rid of jobs but
there's a lot of jobs that are like you
realize
now with the internet instagram and
google that are just like a little fake
you know well also i think the goal for
me too is like
trying to have a the best work
experience which was like not as high of
a priority when you're younger you just
want to work on everything you're like
maybe i'm gonna be a little miserable
but it's a cool project yeah yeah you
know and now i'm like
no no one should be miserable what
that's crazy yeah
like uh so yeah in terms of like
getting to pick the like that's the
impetus to be a little bit more in
control right is to get to pick the
people that are gonna be on the thing
to hopefully have did you have a
honeymoon experience
um yeah i mean you know we did such a
low key we did a super low-key wedding
at our house with just our parents and
our siblings
you've said it on another podcast oh
sorry no i didn't know that i had
to repeat yourself so then we had it we
had like a
three night honeymoon i guess at like
the very next day at
uh san ysidro ranch nice
love that place so it was just sort of
like just low-key we just like
went out of town for the weekend so my
main
problem with you is the cat thing
but like why why does it have to be a
versus
why does it have to be a thing it's it
it's like there's been so many obstacles
in our uh
imminent best friendship and it was like
my shame about
you being on cooler shows than i was on
and then
like and then i like cats and you like
dogs like but i also like dogs have you
not noticed
how i'm interacting with you but you're
also a very good actress so i don't
know i would never fake being kind to
your
dogs what kind of monster
do you i mean i definitely could but
like what kind of yeah are there
insane monsters good actresses are my
nightmare
i'm i'm like i'm always like flattered
that
you think i'm that good of an actress
that i would be that crazy to do that
but like i genuinely enjoy other
people's dogs
most of the time and i had a dog we had
a dog
and cats growing up and i'm just more of
a cat person and this is also more of a
dave thing too
like i went through a phase pre-dave
where i was like i don't want to get
married and i don't have kids and i
don't have pets and i don't have a plant
just get all the shit out of my way i
don't want any of it i don't want any
responsibility
i want none of it and dave and then i
met dave and he was like
i have two eight-year-old cats i was
like great
great move them into my house yep it's
it's a hassle until
we're on i mean
yeah but also i had grown up with cats
and i've always been like a cat person
we had
i mean cats what is it when i was in
college my roommate had a cat we had a
cat in our dorm room
yeah like i know it sounds gross
and maybe it kind of was but i loved
that little guy
i loved it his name was yarmeer yeah it
probably kinda is but our dorm rooms
were actually pretty sizable and we had
at cal arts it was like uh two like
pretty big dorm rooms shared a bathroom
so like the cat had free reign of like
pretty much those two rooms in the
bathroom so it was like a bigger
like pretty good way when you get mad do
you get mad about anything
um yeah
but i've always been more of like like
it's worked this out
no i was going to say like as a kid more
than getting mad i was like the crying
kid
like i would more just be like that hurt
my feelings like i feel like i'm still
the same
like in different categories i guess
like
with davey if i'm upset about something
it's going to be like more emotional
and now i'm really good at catching
myself like fighting what's a fight
what's a fight
a fight between the two of us is me
being like you know honey i
i just didn't like that's not a fight i
just didn't
appreciate like how you did this then
this and then he's like oh my god i'm
sorry i didn't realize that i did that
you are a scientologist um we're not
yellers either of us
but like i'll get upset about some there
uh i'll get mad
i don't know i'll get upset about things
and then i'll send
like i'm like two days ago i feel like i
like kind of started to get upset about
something
and then i had to send like a member of
my team like a three paragraph email
that was like
i just feel like maybe this was
mishandled like i don't know i wasn't
really mad
that's not a good example because i was
i'll get mad and then i'll like trash
talk with a friend of mine and like get
it out of my system
yeah and then by the time i go to talk
to the person if i do it all
it's like what happened uh-huh
i don't know i'm not a yeller you're so
good at you're so good at conflict
i guess or maybe i avoid it yeah no i
think you're good at it
a little about catchment strategy secure
i think you're secure
what is it that's what it is what do you
mean fuck of course you would say this
what's the tattoo
strategy is like your attachment
strategy based on how much eye contact
uh and physical touch you got as a child
is basically
um uh uh ordains your attachment
strategy and how you
attach to other people it's it's super
complicated i bet i have a good one
because i think my parents were like
i think very eye contact detached secure
is like
very rare uh
it's incredibly annoying that you
are secure well i don't really know
anything about this so i'll just take
your word
yeah yeah yeah yeah maybe the fact that
i don't know nobody is proves that
you're secure
i'm sorry and he's secure too he dies
are
the fucking we got a lot of eye contact
we got a lot of physical effects i'm
worried something really bad is going to
happen to you
yeah because your life is going to so
you know what i'm saying yeah like
that's my like
the other shoe is going to dry like when
is the shoe going to drop
yeah for sure it could happen you had
some cats die
yeah they'd be okay but they were very
old okay
look it'll happen like i can't think
about it you can't live your life with
something bad i do
i guess
when something really bad happens i get
kind of psyched because i'm like
okay that's out of the way yeah i mean
look my parents are both still alive so
like that'll be a the big thing right
when they when they go
that's going to be a daunting thing uh
i mean you know bad things have happened
but not that bad
it's true i i've been fucking lucky yeah
some bad things have happened for sure
but like
not things that were not you're not i
don't i don't describe you lucky this is
why i like you i don't think you're
lucky i think you
work your ass off it's both i think it's
both
it's got to be both come on come on now
come on a lot of people work hard yeah
there's a lot of luck too yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's true
your bone structure your nose job i
swear
i don't think you out of nowhere i swear
i don't i also don't think
what like i wouldn't lie about it oh
that's what i'm saying
so it's like assuming it's like i don't
know why i wouldn't just be like yeah
it's like i would be like i did and
here's the doctor he's the best
and i think that i'm trying to think
because i got filler on the side of my
nose
because it like forever they asked me to
get a nose job
like who asked you my ent was like you
have a deviated septum we need and i was
like i
actually oh i don't think i should go
down this road
because i know myself well that's the
thing
the female comics that came before me
yeah like it's not a
i know i feel like fair amounts of
slippery plastic surgery in my family
history
and so i get i'm a little nervous about
that like it's tattoos like i i know if
i start
i will never stop it it's quacking the
same i get nervous about it too yeah
but so i was like i don't want that and
also i was
known enough to where you'll be able to
tell you'll be able to tell
and i was just like yeah i i have
crooked nostrils and
everybody knows it and people make fun
of me about it and if i change it like
remember when jennifer gray got annoyed
i was just going to bring that up never
worked again
killed her career it's like the it's
like she's the that's what we love about
that's what we
loved about you yeah but but you should
be able to do that
you should i don't want to i like my
nose i'm sorry um um she should have
she's just for gracious you should be
able to do whatever you want but like
yeah like yeah yeah for sure um but yeah
so i got filler in the side of my nose
and i feel like that's why we were
talking about i was like maybe i had
just gotten it and i was like oh did you
get a nose job because you can also
yeah yeah maybe such a touchy subject
it's such a like
i know it's taboo because we all want to
be like i don't know i'm trying to like
because i have a nervousness about
seeing
people that i know having gotten a lot
of do like do a lot of that
and i've watched the slippery slope
happen that like
i'm more i'm trying to do the like the
microcurrent facials on myself every day
with like my thingy at home you know
what i mean my zip no i do the zip the
zip oh okay we're doing the zip
um it's a little i've done a little bit
of botox
but it's worn off by now yeah no
i know because of the fucking quarantine
i know mine is totally worn
i don't do that one just right here and
they laugh at me because i'm like don't
give me too much because you have to
always
tell them the amount and the doctor's
like i just don't think that
does much at all and i'm like only do
because you have to have give me those
12 units he's like 12.
let me do 20. i'm like do not do 20. i'm
obsessed with you
i'm like i am and then i'm such a good
actress that i'm acting like a doctor
i've sat with him for 20 minutes being
like should i go up to 14.
i just don't know like what's a year 12
to 14 it seems so crazy maybe the 12 is
fine but i feel like i could use the
extra two he's like
it's such little difference because
they're really they're not doing much at
all
they think their job is to make you have
no i
i will say wrinkles is a sign of youth
at this point well i would say
oh yeah i mean people get wacky with
that stuff but i will say
the guy that i've gone to to do that
stuff is like a great uh
he's a good dermatologist and he is not
a pusher which is what i like about the
guy
he's more like that's great i'll do
whatever you want and when will you come
in
finally to get your like full body moles
moles i know because i need to do that
yeah
oh i don't have time today give me that
shot
give my daughter the shot
my moles are my moles it's fine we're in
choir
we're in choir i've actually been the
tannis i shouldn't say that guys i've
been getting a lot of outdoor time
because we live in l.a because i always
go like oh cancer will be
cured by the time it's cancer it'll be
fixed by that it's not a good stretch i
need this now
high def television is a nightmare i
know but then i get
on your skin well first i was going to
say i get melasma which sucks which is
you know where you get like a
discoloration kind of it's i think it's
from my birth control that if i'm in if
i get one uh
nortrell that's not real
for briefly it was decetta i think but
i'm i believe it's nortrel
i've never heard of a birth control i've
never heard of
search it you don't think there's a
nortel what do i use on my skin i have
i'm just saying i've
there's never been like i've never not
heard of a birth control i've never
there's no birth controls i haven't been
on nor trial yeah is this one where you
skip your period
no but like they're so light yeah yeah
i basically skipped my period but you
still have that week of pills that's
like how long have you did we have been
on it
on birth control in general probably
just as long as i've been with
davey yeah yeah yeah yeah what i use on
my skin i have a great facialist
biba d'souza uh-huh biba los angeles and
i get my products from her pretty much
so you do everything they she says are
they available to buy
yes biba los angeles what does that work
b-i-b-a it's her first name
okay got it okay okay okay some people's
names are bieber thank you sorry i'm
problematic
we've been over this um i love her and
adore her she's so
fixed my skin and it helped me to not be
like
it was never that bad but i used to be a
bad picker like a family of pickers so i
was just like
i feel like on the community days there
were just days where you're like telling
scripty like
in post can we it's a script supervisor
scripty i'm working like filming tv very
inside so
if you have like a huge zit you can tell
now i'm for the listeners
supervisor i've never done that you can
tell the script supervisor to mark it
and then in post production they can
like you know
cgi i've never done that and i
guess that's what gift
to you claiming your space i mean i
only learned about it because our makeup
artists on community would
every so often be like we already told
scripty and i'd be like
what yeah told them what yeah it's the
fact that we're
so cool have makeup on all day and have
good stuff and then have perfect skin
yeah and there's people that like
stress like i feel like you always get
that zit right before you start a job
when your skin's been perfect yes
and also even like a week ago like just
when i'm like every time i get to like
i know you think i'm so well adjusted
but still there are always these hurdles
where i get to that really good
place where i'm feeling like
everything's going well and i feel good
in my life
and then when i'm in that spot i'm
always like and this will be it
forever like i'm so glad i'm done
picking my face
forever and then two hours later i'm
like
except and then i have this like gash in
the middle and i'm like
and then i just have to sit there and
deal with the
the guilt of like face picking did that
to myself it's an addiction you did that
too
it's very addictive yeah it's very
addictive but those pimple patches that
i just learned about a week ago
i don't know are actually the most
amazing thing for that and if i could
sound like a commercial for a minute it
blew my mind
so like a week ago i picked a zip right
here well the one i bought
is like a band-aid brand like next nexus
nexium called um pimple starface
no no no the one i use no no i mean yes
these are all of them
the one i use is a band-aid company
that starts with n-e-x and i forget what
the rest of the word is
next so basically it's
like hydrocolloid i don't know if i'm
pronouncing that the right way stars
mighty next care next care acne
absorbing cover
so my friend had told me to get these a
while ago and i had tried one once and
was like this is bullshit and then just
stuck them in a drawer
and then a week ago my you know i was
going
to present at the people's choice awards
and had to and and like my skin had been
perfect for months and then of course my
makeup guys got there and i was like
you have to sort of rebuild my skin in
this area
sorry and she was like you should throw
a pimple patch on it tonight i was like
um she was like well
it can't be bad for it and i was like i
guess i'll try it
mind blown okay have you ever used those
band-aids
that you put on a um oh yeah blister yes
and it turns white do you know what i'm
pregnant um
i turns white really care for my feet
i don't okay we'll let them bleed this
is that for your face
it's a little thing you put it over your
pimple and
i think the skin kind of needs to be
open for it to work because basically
it's like it's perfect for if you pop a
zit and you're not sure if you got
anything out you should sleep you have
to keep it on at least like four to six
hours so it's best to use it overnight
cortisone
in it no it's just this hydrocolloid
and it's used basically it keeps the
area moist but it's protecting it from
bacteria i'm telling you i should get a
campaign
i by the way because i truly believe
this shit no joke
it protects your skin from incoming
bacteria it keeps it moist
while sucking out all the oil and pus
in your zit for real and when you take
it off in the morning it's like
all white this is why it's cold it is
the coolest i just
use them for four days and like truly
it's
not salicylic acid some of them have
that in them but i don't trust that
i don't trust my producers never laugh
at any interviews
and they are very into this because of
your pronunciation
wow salicylic acid this is amazing i'm
really glad we're talking about this
it's like have you seen those
commercials oh my god i'm looking at the
reviews
great product bad packaging fuck
you guys you people are
why worse i agree amazing product
hate the packaging fuck you
i like that it's by a band-aid brand and
that i know it's legit and they're not
trying to sneak like perfume into it
yeah yeah yeah
like horse of course i don't or like
it's like a cool pattern like it's like
zebra print and you're like i i'm
sleeping in this zit covering so i don't
touch it
like that's a game changer yeah
a little hormonal acne on the chin well
again i feel like they don't always when
when they don't work it's a real letdown
but i think it has to be in my mind it
has to have just been popped
it has to just at least have a little
opening or it can't so
that's sucking the stuff out your skin
is porous though i know but i'm telling
you
i've used it before on something you
just lost your sponsorship i know
okay here's what look i i have not
experienced
this but i feel like friends of mine
have put it on
a zit that they felt like was like
forthcoming and about to be like a
monster
yes and they felt like it did help
decrease it
i do the prescription cortisone cream
that's legit
it's legit but it's but long term it's
like if it's like
shooting something tomorrow you know
going out with that guy
that doesn't want to date me tomorrow um
put it on and it's like it does do
long-term
damage though cortisone is not good
long-term it cleans your skin long-term
like a lot of the lasers do that too i
know i did a lot of uh
like lasers early on that i wish i
hadn't
i'm just trying to do a lot of nano
current and then i also
bought like a vibrating you know gold
bar yeah and i also bought like
these two silver balls that you keep in
the yeah yeah yeah
you're on for de-puffing and like like
like lymphatic drainage
same purpose yeah i try to do all that
derma rolling
no wow what's that interesting
good i don't want to know because i
don't know
things are going great for me so i don't
know yeah i was gonna say i don't
you actually you do need to do less
movies i feel like you
you need to like take some time i don't
want that yeah
i don't want you getting any younger so
i'm not gonna collect it thank you for
sharing your secrets i'm not going to
share mine
you know what though i've never got that
i remember once i had worked with
some people on a movie and i was telling
somebody about did you ever go to shape
house to do that like i did
infrared yes steam esteem it's an
infrared sauna
and you're going to like that it's a
it's a sleeping bag
it's yes but it's not steam it's like
sauna so it's dry heat sleeping bag and
you do it for an hour and you sweat a
ton
supposed to like help you lose weight
but it's really just sort of like yes
getting the taxes out whatever it is it
feels good i like it
i used to have a what do you call it
like a subscription to that place so i
would go
like a membership yeah um and i was
doing press for some movie and i told
one of the other actors about it and
they were sort of like oh
and then they were like i mean you
shouldn't tell people that because like
now we're gonna do it like someone else
was like oh don't tell her that because
now she's gonna do it and look better
than you i was like old
the fuck do i care if she also sweats
like
like you're like no one can look better
why would i don't worry that's
impossible such a weird
god speed barrier that's just a weird
people that think that way i'm like oh i
am like i i'm like that i have such a
scarcity complex
do you yes because um i remember when i
was a kid my sister and i
when my dad would put down like chicken
nuggets we'd grab them and lick them all
so the other one so that no one else
would eat them with food i have a thing
because i'm
a really slow eater and often everybody
would eat all the stuff
and then i would be like like i wouldn't
get yeah
like like when dave and i first started
dating if he was like
picking off my plate i'd be like this is
my food
you have to be patient and let me eat it
like i'm eating it so slowly that you're
thinking i'm like one of those actresses
that just picks and doesn't eat but i do
want to eat it all
but it's gonna take me some time you are
a cat
yeah my mom used to leave me at the
dinner to like they just like clear all
the food and wash the dishes and i'd
still be like
i'm finishing i think that's exactly
what you're saying fearless
never in a rush i don't know you're kind
of reminding me of sebastian maniscalco
a little bit
oh i'll take that i mean just what and
just it's just in terms of his approach
to life is like i'm doing what i'm doing
and i'm going to do it perfectly and on
as long as it takes is how long it's
going to take like that i'm no one's
rushing me
totally except i'm not gonna like be
taking so long other people are
put out yeah but if i i mean it's put
myself out i'm gonna put you out because
i'll be resentful towards you so let's
avoid a future resentment i'm gonna do
what i'm gonna take care of me
yeah and that's the most selfless thing
you can do that's so
interesting now now things are making
sense now that i was able to like find
another person that you remind me of
okay i like this for our relationship
yeah this is
now i like okay now i know how to deal i
know
good good good good get get get get get
good
good i'm obsessed with you you know i
end these super awkwardly
oh is there anything we should have
is there anything we should have covered
is there anything i should about that
you're surprised i didn't ask
that i should have no but i don't know
what's been your least
what have you liked the least about this
about doing this podcast
nothing i don't think am i stressing you
out no not at all oh good
i was gonna more like it's like i want
to say something about something i
worked on but i feel like this is not
like a pluggy type of
podcast but but it is like
i mean we talked about um
well by the time this comes out when
does this come out it's a great question
don't challenge oh okay um uh
promising young woman yeah but it's
always coming out podcasts are
some people listen to this in a year
yeah that's true well there's just
because there's something in mind that
is coming out that came out today
oh give it and it's called marvel 616
what an asshole
it's a new show for disney plus i just
i just figured there's no way you had
more things coming out well this is a
very low-key thing that i feel like
not a lot of people know about this is
what we need to all watch okay well
it's a it's an anthology um documentary
series on disney plus
that marvel has done and i directed an
episode
and it was like my first time doing that
kind of like uh that's a big
documentary style directing
that's even what's your favorite
documentary
i know that's a hard question what are
like some good you know
capturing the freedmen yes yeah of
course was like of course and of course
that was like a staircase
yeah okay who did it
he did
i'm not not behind it you're just
sexist towards men yeah
bye don't write elephants
uh did you see tickled no oh that's a
good one it's
more recent about this yeah it's
definitely i'm very
sensitive and if i watch something
that's really weird it'll
like fuck me up for like a couple days
well here's what you should watch my
marvel 616 episode because it's
darling it's like a feel-good episode
about high school kids doing
theater six one seven these marvel ones
don't know if you've heard of it
yeah it's super sweet and also gillian
jacobs directed an episode
also like how cool what a delight yeah
and then
um sorry i know you're like anything
else we should talk about about you i'm
like
well um
this is what we do that's my type anus
coming out
charming shit about it adorable
um i did start watching the newest
amanda knox documentary
the the new or newer one my friend
produced uh the fir the the one that was
on netflix
yes and they also produced marvel 616.
no and it's davey's uh high school
friend
she's coming on the podcast in a couple
weeks amanda knox yes
cool
that that tickled me the most of
anything in this podcast
whoa watching the documentary yes
i want to see the new one you could play
her
i should you sure but you know you
already did yes
tayden panettieri already did i'll play
her i'll come on the podcast also as
her we'll have her in the other room so
it's like her real
answer she's going to direct you and i
have an earbud it'll direct you
and then i give them yeah yeah it's good
it's very meta it's very like charlie
kaufman
so that was so accurate yeah i haven't i
didn't watch the octopus teacher i can't
because it makes me too sad
oh i haven't oh is it sad i've been
really wanting to watch
with animals i just i get too sad what
about uh uh
planet earth too i don't have an i'm not
into weed enough i don't think that's
true i get that i like it it's kind of
like this feels like a screensaver i do
watch screensavers
planet earth 2 actually like is
phenomenal where they actually grass
tyson
the other guy they make it i love how
they like tried to cancel neil degrasse
tyson
it just like didn't take did they i
wasn't privy to it
i didn't read about it i don't read
about all the cancellations all the time
yeah
um planet earth 2 they really like
dramatize everything in a way that's
very compelling and entertaining did you
watch the vow
yeah and now i want to watch the other
one
i have such a bad thing about india you
have to watch it
because i have such a hot take on it oh
i'll watch it and i'm gonna watch
but but you you're gonna like it because
you think
that he did it in the staircase i
already know what you're going to think
that's very judgmental and you're a cat
person so i already know what you're
going to say
and i'm a capricorn which is what i
thought you were right about to say like
just knowing that about oh my god i knew
i was
driving this out for a reason i also
have a theory that the fact that you
were born on december 29th
is very traumatic and why you're such a
great performer because you had to
compete with jesus christ
well it's not like i was born on
christmas you were born on the 29th of
december no
what day no one cared about your
birthday you were no true you were not a
priority
my parents cared about not really they
it was a hassle for them
no it wasn't they just bought you a
christmas present now they have to throw
your birthday party and they're going to
do a new year's thing today
they loved it my parents loved it even
worse
proving my point too many presents and
my biggest problem was that like my
presence
went out of style by the time it was my
next birthday i didn't have like a cool
june birthday and got like the good news
because like you feel like you were like
horses you know you didn't get out of
school you didn't get to like have the
birthday
yes it sucks it sucks it doesn't
everyone was like taking the tree out
like taking the lights down it mostly
sucks because nobody's around so you're
right it's like when you're a kid
you're not in school and that's where
you want to be in school
and then when you're an adult you're not
at work which is the which is a plus
it's been a real plus that i can now i
just get out of town always but like
being born and raised in l.a and no
one's from here so like come my birthday
everyone's
gone what is it like dead city people
that have birthdays
near holidays or between holidays the
december
you know yeah 23rd babies and the
february 15th and like it's it's weird i
mean i think my parents
oh like overcompensated by being like we
always have to be with you on your
birthday and like really make it a thing
into my adult life where i'd be like you
know who i don't want to be with on my
sad birthday
just my parents yeah yeah yeah like your
joke because i've done
those a couple times and it's way worse
yeah
so now we just we literally it's like a
witness at the gynecologist's office
it's just what are you like
why we get out of town it's it's great
it actually has worked to my advantage
in that i always know
it's the two weeks when nobody's working
dave and i go somewhere sometimes a
couple friends come so it's all great
yeah
but trust me i still still even doing
that
we've had birthdays where we're trapped
on a plane
first seven hours on the tarmac and then
we finally get where we're going
and our friends are like hi
uh sorry we're doing obviously we're so
glad you're staying here and it's a
great vacation oh it's your birthday um
yeah totally here we go we did get we
got you a piece of cake and i'm like
you're like bitch i'm like this is four
movies a year
in ten years well i used to be like i
used to just be like
i don't even care i don't care about my
birthday and i don't want to celebrate
it so that's great and then i
did like a couple years ago i think that
what actors do i think what
entertainers do is we make like i was
like i don't want to get married it's
like but i make every day my wedding day
i i don't get to no one's my birthday
september 4th the first day of school
always labor day
so i never get to have birthdays so like
i make every day my birthday
like it's like we ha i just so you also
feel like you have a bad birthday
so we're connecting on them like yeah i
think i'm just
overshadowed by the first day of school
i was no one
it was like hi my name's whitney and
someone go is it your birthday and i'd
be like yeah and they'd be like
cool happy birthday like oh and now we
feel uncomfortable like my trapper
keeper is broken
like everyone was just like like it was
just like a weird
i could never had parties i never my
parents i do think they always tried to
throw a cool party where like
we were doing a fun activity when i was
in elementary like my mom would get a
bunch of shirts and like puff paints and
we'd do like
like before birthday party now parents
are crazy and they get like yeah
like they said yeah like shooting
fireworks
stupid but back then we did like low-key
cool stuff yeah
anyway cool theory
oh that was
a little that was like
a little sliver of anger came out like i
feel like a little bit of reel
i feel like there's something she
doesn't have anything else to say about
it something real is coming up i don't
have anything else to say about it this
feels real
so cool theory this feels real
no i feel like we've just totally i
think it's a great theory
i feel like we just undone the entire
progress we made
i'm getting closer we took a turn
i hit i hit a nerve not at all i didn't
mean it that way at all i was sort of
just
wrapping up when you
tell someone ask someone if they're mad
all of a sudden everything they do
proves no matter what the yeah are you
mad i'm not mad it is i know i'm really
not mad
but like if you didn't accuse me of it
now all of a sudden everything
it's like when someone call is like
you're being crazy i'm not being crazy
totally there's nothing and then even if
you get really calm then that's also
there's nothing you can do i'm not so
i'm like oh you're upset
when someone accuses you of doing
something it's over you're guilty
you're right thank you
um okay so uh
planet earth i've googled all these
things you told me have you seen marvel
paddington
too don't i'm not doing this hipster
padding you've never seen paddington two
sona hill and seth rogens
can't stop tweeting about paddington too
is that true yeah i don't go on twitter
everyone's very uh
you're better than me i can't everyone's
so obsessed with paddington too i don't
i'm like good i'm sure i'll watch it but
you're probably right though
maybe it's a weird thing that if you
don't yeah i gotta get a little like i
love
paddington too but you definitely don't
have i didn't see paddington one and i
still really love paddington too and
it's maybe a career best performance by
hugh grant
are you watching that new show i gotta
go which one i know we're trying to
remember he plays a priest
no a priest i'm good on hugh grant well
maybe i haven't watched that you
are yeah i'm fine oh not me somebody
sounds like a
anti-paddington too i was like like are
those movies like
dotting hill like you just were saying
how much you loved
nottingham it's well made you compared
my movie to notting hill in a flattering
way and now you're gonna shit on
nottingham
we have to cut just start
a lot of sugar's kicking in i do need a
snack
this is
don't worry i have one in my bag
i have one on it i meant i have a snack
i have a bar i have a really good nut
bar wait i do have some seeds
um i have my own i just like that whole
what was the one where
they all fell in love with the help love
actually
yeah like sure i never liked that shit i
know i
i know it works i know it's good i did
do
i did a move i did a pr not a movie i
did like a mini series once that shot in
london and all the british people were
like
why do americans love love actually like
that shit is stupid i was like
i don't know don't don't put it all on
me here's my thing with hugh grant i
don't like the like
i'm so nervous and not like weddings in
a funeral
i don't remember it i just i don't like
i mean i don't like flustered men
okay well that's why together you will
appreciate paddington to
you grant because now he's like i'm
making choices and i'm a totally
different type of
i don't like when men like pretend
they're weak
and like we're supposed to be like oh
but he's just flustered and nervous
like no you're not yeah okay you're fine
i don't disagree but but i also like i
agree together
i agree with you and i like hugh grant
you're gonna have to pick one i won't
i know he's skill and we're like just
yeah i don't know
no i like him and and he's aging like a
fine wine
he's making great choices i'm a harrison
for his latter years
yeah sure i'm into him too okay you can
like both
and you can i'm going to agree with you
you can agree with you
and like hugh graham i'm a black and
white person you're
great you're like i'm in the gray area
two things can be true
okay don't ride elephants we love you
guys
you